e
audio there we go it's audio in here now
too thank yeah so anyway um where we are
with the Overflow rooms I'm going to be
calling for example the person that's
speaking now we're going to have just
like baseball the person that's up next
and the one that's on Deck um or in the
hole and so we're going to try to give
notice to people that are outside in the
other two areas now I also would like to
we have a researcher here a committee
assistant and that's Jennifer four um if
there are folks out here that have very
very young children or if you need to be
out of here to pick up a youngster at
school I as a past school teacher and
administrator understand and principal
understand that need and as a parent now
as a Granddad um I think I'd like to get
all those people in those categories up
as quickly as possible after we go
through the Reps so would you please
contact Jennifer 4 and she can on a
piece of paper write down those names
and I will go through those names to try
to expedite and get you out of
here there's some also other people that
may have real real long distances I'm
talking about cobbrook and places like
that I'm not talking about Bo I'm
talking about cobbrook or down maybe way
down on the ocean or maybe over as far
far over as you can go in the
Connecticut River towards Charleston or
the other direction if you live half in
Maine and half out of it um your
fortunate liveing this side of the line
please also let Jen know so I really try
to get people in and out of here so uh
also as a rule here in the house we do
not want anybody eating in the rooms or
drinking anything other than
H2O and that's uh I ask that you think
about drinking water while you're
testifying these rooms are very very dry
and you're sitting here for an hour two
3 hours your body starts to notice that
so please have some water or get water
there is a bottle cooler right out in
the hallway um I don't know if there's
cupso but uh you can fill up if you have
to there so with that I'd like to
welcome people to the committee one
other thing of noticed is that when you
come up we do not want any paraphernalia
or butt or bulletin or signs anything
like that we are uh looking for you to
testify without that assistance um
please come forward uh explain where you
are whether you're supporting or opposed
and and and go on with your presentation
please don't repeat what others have
already said try to summarize as much as
possible with that I'd like to welcome
uh Valerie McDonald she's the
representative who's going to be
presenting the bill I see her eagerly
waiting at your seat so welcome Valerie
to our hearing today thank you chairman
lad and good afternoon to you all as
well and to everyone in this room in the
Overflow of rooms as well for the record
my name is Valerie McDonnell I represent
my friends and Neighbors in my hometown
of Salem which is Rockingham District 25
and I am the prime sponsor of the bill
before you which is House Bill 115
FN I brought this legislation forward
for a number of reasons primarily to
fund students not systems to ensure
educational attainment is not limited
due to a student's income or zip code
which are both beyond the child's
control and to make strides upon what
was accomplished during a committee of
conference over the summer I served on
that committee along with a number of
you as well and as well as members of
the other body feeling that the final
report was too much of a compromise from
the original House position the house
ultimately voted not to accept the
report and as a result of that committee
no changes were made to the statutes
regarding education Freedom accounts
House Bill 115 FN would change the
statute but only slightly the only
change is to strike income limitations
from the eligibility requirements which
effectively removes less than a sentence
from current law the English teachers
Among Us May note that the bill attempts
to repeal a depending Clause from
current law however this modest bill
will have significant benefits for
example every New Hampshire family would
be empowered to choose an educational
setting that best fits their needs and
is most conducive to their child's
learning current EFA participants attend
non-public homeschooling and even public
education options such as our wonderful
public charter schools two of which are
located within my district but service
students across the granite
state additionally and I seldom hear
this point mentioned EF are permitted to
be spent on testing fees this enables
participants to take exams for college
credit such as AP or advanced placement
exams these exams which are administered
by the college board can be costly the
current cost ranges from $99 to
$147 per exam and considering students
often take multiple AP exams and
families often have multiple students
taking these exams it can become a large
financial burden however these exams do
make higher education not only more
affordable but also more attainable and
as a result there would be less of a
need to debate other issues in
committees such as this like loan
forgiveness because there'll be less of
a need for students to take out loans
and I can personally attest to the
benefits the AP program which combined
with dual enrollment allowed me to
complete College in half the time and at
a fraction of the cost and hb15 appn
would afford every student the same
opportunity
furthermore the EFA program is both
wildly successful and wildly popular
notably 72% of K through 12 parents
support
esas and 69% of those students support
Universal
esas I mention esas or education savings
accounts which is a term used in other
states for the sake of
comparison recently arizonans passed
Universal esas in their state and a new
report suggests that the resulting
expenditures came in under budget and
the same can be true in New Hampshire
and that report is provided to each of
you uh for specifics I do direct you to
the attached fiscal note on the bill
where the legislative budget assistant
estimated the average EF gr a grant If
This Were to pass to be
$441 19 per student and on the other
hand the Department of Education through
their I platform software checked this
morning
estimates the average cost per pupil to
be
$23,995 and that amount keeps increasing
year to year so I said something to the
English teachers now to the Math
teachers in the room you may note that
4,419 subtracted from
$1,580 which is an extreme tax
savings also under current law when a
family's income is assessed to determine
if they qualify the efaa program their
expenses are not considered this was
brought to my attention by chrisy who is
a mother of two young children in
Swansea after an intensive search for
the right fit her children are learning
in a way that meets their special needs
having an annual income over the current
limit the family has been self-
financing
this unfortunately Christy's husband was
recently diagnosed with terminal brain
cancer specifically stage for gleo
blastoma and as a result of paying for
Cancer Treatments the family's expenses
have dramatically increased and as a
result they can no longer afford their
children's
education the option that was finally
working for her children the couple are
taxpayers they're small business owners
and several years ago they decided to
make New Hampshire their new home so
needless to say they contribute to the
New Hampshire community and don't
deserve to choose between paying for
cancer
treatment and to educate their special
needs children at your leisure I
encourage you to read christe's
testimony which is in front of each of
you however I will note that it was
difficult not to be moved to tears when
I spoke with Christie twice this week in
the provided testimony you will also
hear the story of Amy from Auburn who
says an EFA allowed her son to read at
grade level and catch up with his peers
Renee from Troy she cites that her
children's efas are Miracles and Hannah
from antrum credits an EFA with saving
the life of her daughter who
unfortunately experienced sexual
assault these are just excerpts of a few
of the testimonies supported submitted
in support of House Bill 115 FN and
there is more testimony in front of you
and available digitally including from
each of your
constituencies I find myself reading
through these testimon again and again
they remind me of the reason that I am
here which is to help
people many of the stories in front of
you which I encourage you to read when
you get the chance are from parents and
Educators alike and they are crying out
to us for help isn't that our job as
legislators to help them after all if we
don't help our constituents meet their
educational needs then what are we doing
here thank you and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions for the
representative yes yes represent
luno uh thank you very much Mr chair
thank you very much representative
McDonald for uh for bringing forward
this um this bill um just um um it's
it's really one question but it's it
it's tied to your some of the comments
you made and your your opening remarks
you you talk about this being a um um
just a slight change compared to
existing law so I just want to make sure
uh I understand where you're going with
that I believe existing law um uh has
the program providing vouchers and by
the way I'm using the term vouchers
because I know some states call them
efas some states call them esas some
states may use other terms as well but
vouchers I think is the universally
generic term for programs like this but
um but uh currently under state law uh
state New Hampshire will provide uh
vouchers to um to students who who are
in families earning up to 350% of the
poverty guideline and that's about um
right right at the um the median
household income Statewide so by
removing the income cap this bill and I
just want to make sure I get this right
because you're talking about a slight
change this bill would make these
vouchers available to families making
well above the uh median household uh
income uh am I correct in that thank you
for the question representative And in
regards to a slight change I was
referring to the language of the bill
itself and if you were to look the bill
not including the fiscal note is less
than a page I'm referring specifically
to lines 4 through 8 where you notice
that
literally par of a sentence is crossed
off not an entire sentence as regard to
the change the 350% of the federal
poverty guidelines that is a figure
given to us by the federal government
it's a guideline used for a number of
programs that's not controlled within
the state of New Hampshire
whatsoever um that number so that number
could change but currently for a family
and so in regards to a slight change I
was referring atmology to the language
within the bill
um this bill would expand it to all am
regardless of income because currently
other factors as I mentioned such as
expenses are not included okay and
follow follow we're going to try to stay
with from followup so if you can ask a
quick question it's G to be real Qui
tied tied to that so the answer is yes I
I believe I I characterize it correct
the existing law and the what's being
proposed here and then in terms of the
modest um nature of this bill and that's
another term you used when when opening
the the program up to families earning
uh above and well above the um the the
med Statewide median household income
we're looking at at Cost growing by more
than $100 million a year isn't uh isn't
that
correct I would not agree with those
cost estimates I do have in front of you
provided from the Arizona State where
they are a universal State their
programs structured a little bit
different than ours but their cost
estimates were seen a little bit
differently um And in regards to the
term modest I do think it's only a
modest request that every child has an
education that meets their needs I don't
think that's asking for too much for a
student um and I hope that answers your
question thank you thank you very much
further questions yes representative
fellows thank you um you made a comment
that there was a tax savings you
referred to the 20,000 or so cost
average cost of an education which
includes Revenue that came from federal
sources and local sources and state
sources and then you subtracted the
average cost of Education Freedom
account voucher and declared that was a
tax savings so I'm a little confused by
that because if the student it goes to
was already attending Pro school that's
not a tax savings to taxpayers or the
state that's an expenditure for the
state and if the student you have a
question you need in form of a question
and if the student was in public school
then they will lose some of their
adequacy aid so can you explain to me
exactly who's saving taxes here to
clarify the figure I was citing is on
the Doe's website if you go to their I
platform click on I report the number is
right there and that's
$3,999 as of this morning when I
checked and in reference to the savings
I am referring specifically
to parents when they choose to put their
kid in an alternative education their
child that meets their needs the savings
is
um I'm struggling a little bit to
understand your question when you're
saying that students that are already in
perhaps a private school that that
because the the way the question is
worded with all respect implies that
that itself was not a choice and so for
that family there's tremendous savings
and at the moment you did mention Public
Schools we currently do have phase out
grants going to the public schools to
make up for any loss to that school that
they would receive an adequacy
aid thank you very
much not yes repres
Damon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question would you support amending the
bill to require the the department of
education's contract with the children's
Scholarship Foundation which administers
the program include data sharing
requirements so that taxpayers in the
state have more complete information on
how the program is operated and the
funds are administered and so that the
ongoing audit of the program could be
accurately completed with all the data
needed
thank you for the question it's nice to
see you again representative as for the
children's scholarship fund I do know
they have Representatives here so that
question may be better opposed to them
however as regarded in the EFA statutes
the third party that administers a
program which is currently the
children's scholarship fund is able to
operate the program and take 10% for
administrative fees it is my
understanding that the children's
scholarship fund is using far less
closer to seven or eight% for exact
percentage I would again refer to the
children's scholarship fund so that
reporting information is completely
available to the best of my
knowledge
yes thank you Mr chair to be more clear
my question was not about the amount of
money paid to Children's Scholarship
Foundation to administer the program
although that's a separate concern my
question is about getting the
information on how the money is being
spent what it is that we are paying for
As taxpayers and we're not getting that
information
so the question is would you support
amending the bill to include a
requirement that full data sharing
happen from children's Scholarship
Foundation as the sole entity
administering this to provide complete
data to the Department of
Education I do know for a fact the
children's Scholarship Foundation on
their website does have a list of
regulated expenditures that are
permissible throughout the program and I
do know that it is monitored through an
application known as class wallet so all
expenses are double checked it's not
that a family can purchase something
without a separate check from the
children's scholarship fund from class
wallet and only from certified retailers
so it is my best understanding that that
information is already available if it's
the data sharing you're asking that
would be a question better directed to
the scholarship fund themselves thank
you no further question thank you very
much for being here today and best of
luck during the upcoming session thank
you I'd like to invite representative
Howard representative Howard here Mr
chair yes he's in another hearing I'll
text him if you can just he'll come in
that'd be
Thomas thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the committee for the record
I am representative Wendy Thomas and I
represent the town of marac I'm here
today in opposition to HB 115 which
removes the income cap for the voucher
program uh mechanical error okay I was
say I just
started I had two seconds not two
minutes excuse me okay um the my
concerns with HB 115 include increased
costs for public fund funds the voucher
program often diverts money from public
schools which serve the majority of
students to private schools which serve
fewer students this can lead to unfunded
Public Schools larger class sizes
reduced programs and inadequate
resources for teachers and students
specifically in New Hampshire the
state's education Freedom account
program has significantly expanded
initially projected to cost
$130,000 the program exceeded 14.7
million in its second year far
surpassing early estimates this
shortfall means less funding for public
schools which still must educate the
majority of children increased local
taxes when public funds are redirected
to P private schools local taxpayers are
often left to cover the Gap to maintain
Public School Services specifically in
New Hampshire the EFA program is funded
through State dollars but as more
families opt out of public school
fixed costs like teacher salaries
transportation and Facilities remain
with less State funding municipalities
will need to raise property taxes to
make up the difference lack of oversight
and accountability private schools
accepting vouchers are often not held to
the same standards as public schools in
areas like curriculum teacher
qualifications and student performance
this can lead to inconsistent
educational outcomes specifically in New
Hampshire private schools in the if EFA
program are not required to follow the
state's rigorous academic standards or
assessments making it difficult for
parents and policy makers to evaluate
their
effectiveness support for religious
schools voucher programs often direct
public money to religious schools
raising concerns about the separation of
church and state and the promotion of
specific religious
ideologies specifically in New Hampshire
over 75% of the schools receiving funds
through the
EFA program our religious
institutions was that really 2 minutes
that was 2 minutes all
right I'll I'll just give you my final
sentence voting against uh hb15 is one
of the most fiscally responsible actions
you can take for the New Hampshire
taxpayers thank you very much I'm
available for questions okay thank you
very much any questions from the
committee not see you thank you very
much representative thank you
representative
Fairington oh this is that's Howard this
is Howard yeah sorry I was in another
committee meeting oh okay that's okay we
we'll put in then okay all right thank
you so much I so you can hustle back
there yeah I really do apologize uh
sorry I I serve on Edna and we're
meeting right now as well well we have
three members that are other places
right here you can see yes so uh
honorable members of the committee uh Mr
chairman my name is representative Heath
Howard I represent the towns of straford
and barington
and just like the overwhelming majority
of people I possibility for the state
and would operate as a tax subsidy for
the wealthy who are already sending
their kids to private school makes no
sense when we are seeing s serious
budgetary constraints in the formation
of the commission on government
efficiency under governor aot and that
we would pick up the tabs of people who
are willing and able to pay for these
Services it just seems rather
inefficient if you ask me every single
school in the state has minimum required
operating costs that they have to pay
for like heat water electricity
maintenance faculty staff and that's
before getting into things like books uh
lesson plans paper and printing costs my
point is is no matter how many kids
attend a school there are costs that
will remain the same no matter what and
removing These funds from already
struggling districts in order to uh
sorry uh in order to uh pay for people
who were previously paying private
tuition out of pocket will make it even
more difficult to cover base costs last
year we failed to pass increases in
adequacy for both uh funding for both
General and special education and it was
found uh that we have a constitutional
obligation to act as ruled on by the
courts if anything the money we are
spending on this I would rather be spent
on special education because private
schools do not have to adhere to the
requirements of educating with people
with special needs and can ref refuse
service to individuals regardless of how
you feel about the voucher program
itself we have a duty to fund public
education first and the state has been
failing to do that maybe we should
before funding private education for the
wealthiest in our state we should do the
bare minimum and fund public education
first thank you uh and no questions
thank you very much are no questions
thank
farington welcome Mr chairman MERS of
the
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Sam farington and I
represent Rochester Ward 4 I just want
to share with you all a story today
about how one of my constituents in
particular would greatly benefit from
expanding the educational Freedom
account program over the course of the
summer I campaigned I did door-to-door
campaigning this family in particular it
was a father and a mother and when I
handed them my campaign card they saw
that I was in support of expanding
educational Freedom school choice now
after talking with the family I learned
just how important the issue is to them
they have a son and now he's in high
school he goes to a private school here
in New Hampshire but a few years ago he
went to Rochester middle school and at
the time he was a a mediocre student not
a bad kid but just not the best student
and then the father shared with me that
the son was being sexually harassed in
the boy's bathroom at as one would
imagine you you don't know how to
respond your heart breaks um you just
don't know what to say to them and later
on with talking with the father I
learned that he had to pull his kid from
the school you know the school wouldn't
do anything about it or couldn't do
anything about it but that was their
decision as a parent the worst part of
the story is that the father had to go
into debt to pull his kid from the
school and now like I said he goes to
private school and he's a a student and
most importantly his psychological
issues the emotional issues those are
gone I share this story because this
circumstance shows why there is a cause
and a need for the state to to increase
educational Freedom a parent shouldn't
have to go into debt for their son or
daughter to succeed thank you and no
questions thank you very much
representative like to call forward
representative Wendy
Thomas well we need to get over there
then okay okay you're welcome now we're
not going to do it two times uh
Murray thank you hello good morning
afternoon yes than to you uh honorable
members for the record my name is Megan
Murray I represent the towns of Amherst
and Milford um and I'm here in
opposition to House Bill 115 um as hb15
flies in the face of our commitment to
locally elected Public School boards
public education Educators and our
students the EFA voucher uh
wallet uh system has no legal
requirement to financially report to the
Department of Ed to our local boards
even though they may in uh do that from
time to time there's nothing in current
statute that says that they are required
to do so once those funds are dispersed
into these accounts um large amounts of
payments are going to these accounts
with our public taxpayer money um being
placed in those accounts without any uh
any real requirement to report those in
any real significant way back um the
other concern that I have is before we
consider opening these unlimited
expansions is that we're making sure
that we are um taking care of special
education needs this is another sort of
area and component to our education
especially in public education we have a
duty to ate all children um and it is
not clear to me through uh the vouchers
or the wallets whether that is happening
or not because we don't have that
information or data coming back to us um
our school boards do those things report
those things back to the state um though
we may have to travel over to another
third party management software site to
get this data there is nothing in
statute that is requiring that
information to come back to the state of
New Hampshire for fiscal transparency
and oversight um I am strongly uh
opposed on this on behalf of my
constituents uh thank you very much
thank you very much are there questions
from the you willing take questions no
ORS thank you Mr chairman for the record
I'm representative sah ORS represent
chiester and I just wanted to say as
people graduate a students graduate from
K to
12 they have choices they can go to
Dartmouth they can go to Southern New
Hampshire
University they can go to MIT like some
of us in this room Arizona State you can
pick a place and they have that right to
go now why do they have choices why why
would they go to a different University
other than maybe a school here in New
Hampshire because probably that school
offers something that will benefit them
the most I'm a graduate of a Christian
University I why did I go to a Christian
University that was my choice that is
where I thought I would get the most
bang for the buck so why do we limit K
through 12 if we have parents that
believe that that their student would
perform better do better and it we' be
better for that student to go to a
different School whether it's the next
town Public School a chartered Public
School a Christian High School whatever
I don't see why we would want to limit
their choices and by the way I'm really
glad you got to see me today thank you
much like to invite representative
good afternoon good afternoon and thank
you representative Vlad and thank you to
the committee for having the hearing
today my name is Stephanie grund and I
represent Hillsboro County 34 which is
Amherst I'm here today to present my
opposition to hb15 there are many
reasons why and I'll be as brief as
possible impact on public school funding
there is an obligation to support public
education in our town
raising the voucher cap will divert
funds from public school especially in
underfunded districts has there been a
study to ensure that public schools will
continue to be funded
appropriately access to Quality
education vouchers are not adequately
addressing issues to of access to
families in lower inome neighborhoods
because they may lack the resources to
navigate the system or to travel to
other schools especially when they're
not many choices near their Town raising
the income cap will all will just allow
more families that are already private
or religious schools to access the efas
the point of the efas was to ensure
students could leave the program they
are in and find a better pathway if a
student is already in a setting that
works for them then this money is not
for them they already made their choice
who is ensuring that students that are
receiving vouchers are being held to a
high standard of academic performance
are public schools regularly test and
Report the results to the doe one of the
reasons is to ensure schools are Mee the
standards of Education if Public Schools
who take public money are held to high
standard shouldn't any family that takes
public money in the form of vouchers be
held to the same standard before you
lift the income gap there should be a
requirement that all families taking
voucher money are taking the same tests
public school students are to ensure the
money is being used to properly educate
and produce adequate results in the
education it should not matter if a
student is attending a private religious
homeschool or other program there should
be a requirement for testing and
reporting to the doe to ensure students
are receiving the educ ation they
deserve as there has been no true audit
of the current company managing our
state efas there should be no money
flowing through into an audit is
performed I will again point out that
all public schools receive an audit by
an appropriate accounting firm can I
just finish or summarize it very Qui one
last
yes these results show that monies are
being used in accordance with laws and
that what is given to the public is
trusted but right now there's no way to
trust or show that current monies are
being handled legally let's keep the
standards the same thank you thank you
very much questions from the committee
thank you thank you I'd like to invite
Horgan so I'm I'm representing Timothy
Horgan from straford County District 10
which is the town of town of Durham and
um I have some written testimony and
I've actually you ically seen it three
times because I submitted it to the
portal I emailed it to everyone and I Ed
copies around but um anyway so the
program it's my opinion a fiscal Time
Bomb even in its current form and as
others mentioned it's ostensibly limited
to 350 standard federal poverty
guideline but in many case essentially
there already isn't a a uh limit because
once a child qualifies here or she stays
qualified forever even the family's
income increases which would uh Norm be
the case given that most parents are in
the prime earning years at this time
when they're raising their children so
but this bill e in that limitation and
it OB we expect the per to go
dramatically so the fiscal note I just
don't you know it's rather vague I don't
trust it uh I don't trust it at all
um and I I think uh I I attached on the
back my printed Thing analis by a group
called reaching higher in New Hampshire
and I don't necessarily take that as
gospel but that's an extremely
conservative estimate just assuming the
number of private and homeschool
students doesn't increase which of
course it will increase and uh they say
it's 100 to 130 million so that's you
know it's really not affordable giving
the budget situation in our state and uh
anyway the program also is very poorly
designed it creates a huge entitlement
program turns over to a small private
organization with a little our oversight
um that's children's scholarship fund
which is based in New York City although
it does have a small office out in lowon
Road actually on the campus of a local
church and um which has raised another
problem with that organization which is
it's an a group for one typ or private
education I.E religious schools both
parochial Catholic schools and uh uh
Chris so-called christianis and the
Department of Education I think has been
very it's oversight has been extremely
ineffective um and designed the program
is almost impossible to audit anyway so
I think uh private I think this uh these
this is uh private schooling I think at
least at this time with our budget
situation should be funded with private
dollars which they're not evenly
distributed but they are very abundant
and uh our taxpayer dollars should be
saved for public schools so so that's
why and all them thank you very much
and thank you again and you'll be
hearing from me in a few weeks I have a
similar Bill uh about this I know you do
yeah thanks thank you uh representative
stepen
ring thank you Mr chairman and uh
members of the committee um I'm a
representative from Manchester uh Ward
12 uh I received over 50 emails for this
uh in support of this bill today uh well
actually the last few days uh to support
the bill um I didn't receive any that
would say not to support the bill but I
want to come to you from a different
perspective uh being that I was an EFA
recipient uh and my daughter was in the
program I have a different perspective
on how it can actually help um being
that the EFA program was near and dear
to my heart after you know my daughter
went through it I was able to see how it
can help other families and I've seen
that a lot um not not to say that you
know the families that are in the
program uh would have chosen it if there
wasn't a different pathway for it like
with the esa and other programs but to
say that the expansion of this program
would be fiscally irresponsible is
something that you guys have to decide
what I'm telling you right now is that
it I think in in terms of the physical
side of what the kids are actually going
through right now in Manchester we have
26% efficiency scores according to the
Department of Education so the
conversation needs to change um not so
much I mean obviously fiscally
responsibly you need to discuss that and
how that works out but as far as the
children go we need to focus on that and
that's one of the thing that's lost uh
in Manchester I've seen that we've
increased uh about $14 million from the
uh hold Harless grants that were uh
given to the city of Manchester because
of the students the 852 students that
have joined the program um that has
increased the funding of the city of
Manchester schools if you look at it and
that is something that's going to phase
out I believe in 2028 to 2030 so again
the argument is that the schools
definitely have to figure out how to be
able to manage their funding a little
bit better in their budget but there's
two sides to this that the education of
the children that I have firsthand
experience in uh can be far more
approved and again my daughter is signed
up to speak to and she's going to speak
on this to let you see from a kid's
perspective um but beyond that I would
just say that uh I support the program
and I I wish that you would uh vote for
it
timing any questions yes representa
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
make taking my question um you cited
that you had received 50 messages in
support of the bill from constituents
and zero opposing it are you aware that
the current numbers online of folks who
have submitted in support or in
opposition are
744 opposed and
3,17 in I'm sorry I said that backwards
whoops
744 supporting the bill and
3,17 opposing the bill the Statewide
numbers are apparently quite different
from your
constituents I appreciate that and did
not know that number until you just said
it um again I'm only doing what I have
from the emails that I get and again um
I encourage anybody that's listening or
watching to reach out to me tell me
their feelings and opinion about it if
you're in my district so thank
you not see yes represent Luna thanks
very much Mr chair would um would you U
possibly support an amendment um to this
bill that would require the state to
perform an annual audit on the uh the
performance of the program make sure
that it's compliant with um with with
state laws the way other Public
Assistance programs are monitored in the
state to be perfectly honest with you I
haven't looked into that part of the
bill to understand what is already there
I'm hearing it now and I will do my due
diligence and look into it more to
understand it better so I guess that's a
question that I would better answered in
the future when I actually have time to
read that portion of what it currently
says in the law okay thank you thank you
further questions not seeing thank you
very much at this point there are still
five or six reps I want but I also have
some notices there that there are
several parent to have to be out of here
by 2:00 and we're almost on it so uh
this is just I think Michaela deer is on
the other room so here oh you're here
you and Brenda Quinn will be
next we're going to try to unload some
of the the parents and all I appreciate
it thank you good afternoon my name is
Michaela Deiter for the record I serve
on the Dober school board and I'm also
on staff with the New Hampshire school
funding fairness project though today I
speak only for myself I oppose HB 115's
attempt to expand the voucher system in
New Hampshire as I believe it represents
a spending decision our state simply
cannot afford to make an expanded
voucher program is a fiscally
irresponsible use of limited taxpayer
funds approximately 20% of Doper 300 500
students including my son received
special education services last year our
district submitted nearly $58 million of
special education Aid reimbursement
requests the state paid 1.53 million
less than 27% of what was submitted
forcing do taxpayers to make up the $4.2
million shortfall this Gap widens
annually as shown on the chart I've
passed
around this negative this reality
negatively affects all community with
students receiving costly academic
support not just over but we're here to
talk today about vur so I'll tie the two
together this year New Hampshire's
voucher program has cost taxpayers $28
million nearly twice the Statewide
shortfall in the special education Aid
fund reaching higher New Hampshire as
mentioned earlier has predicted
Universal eligibility in this Voucher
Program could cost New Hampshire
taxpayers more than $100 million each
year this spending will not save
taxpayers any money as some proponents
including the person who submitted this
bill have suggested today we must assume
every single private or homeschooled
student in the state could or would
enroll in the voucher program these
students currently receive no State
funding and would be a new liability for
taxpayers meanwhile many districts like
Dover are already not receiving all
necessary funds to adequately educate
their students including those with
disabilities these expenses sit squarely
in the Musto category indeed State and
feder federal laws require it I'm not
here to invalidate anyone's personal
voucher story I'm simply here to remind
the committee that vouchers aren't a
must do they are a want to thank you
very much thank you very
much
questions yes represent luno thank you
very much Mr chair thank you very much
um M deer for for joining us this
afternoon um you talked about um the the
questionable tax savings and I think tax
savings was was one of the things that
the that the sponsor of this bill was
really leaning on heavy but but out of
the um the in the um in the previous
year so the the the last year of the um
of the voucher program where we have
full data from the from the Department
of Education that there were
5,321 students in the uh in the voucher
program but only um only around 200 of
them had actually exited from from their
um their public school to take a voucher
could you sort of contextualize that in
terms of what that means for tax savings
sure yeah in in the do Public School
System we haven't really seen all that
much difference uh the majority of
people as you mentioned who are uh using
the existing Voucher Program are coming
from either uh existing homeschool or
private school relationships I the
numbers that I have seen fluctuate a
little but generally it's around 85 or
90% that I've seen um are never were
using the resources available in the
public education system so I think it is
a misrepresentation to say um each
person who uses an expanded voucher uh
program would be saving this state 19 or
20 or whatever thousand dollar it was
because these students weren't using
taxpayer funds to begin with by contrast
they would start using new taxpayer
funds and in a year where we have budget
shortfalls and concerns about how much
revenue we're raising and how much
revenue we've lost I think it is I I go
back to the phrase fiscally
irresponsible I think it is not money we
have to spend to create new spending for
students who weren't previously
receiving these funds thank you thank
you for the
question further questions we do have a
number of parents waiting to get out of
here representative
Damon thank you thank you for your
testimony um I believe you indicated
that you're a parent of a student who
receives special education services sure
am and I'm thinking that as a school
board uh member you're aware that
children who receive an education
voucher um sign a waiver to not
participate in the federal requirements
for special education sure am could you
comment about that and about your
experiences as a parent of a specialed
student in public school and thank you
thank you for the question absolutely
boy two minutes goes quick I I had
originally had more in there about my
son my 14-year-old is a ninth grader
he's been receiving special education
services since he was seven so he is now
7 years into the public education
program receiving special education
services because of lack of funding he
didn't have a par educator for his
entire sixth and seventh grade year
those are hard years as a middle
schooler to not have the support that
you require and that the federal
government has mandated you deserve
through the individuals with
disabilities Education Act I think it's
essential for us to remember that
students who receive special education
services they are the only students in
the country who have a federally
protected right to a free and public
education and as I mentioned this is why
I included the data I did as I mentioned
when you have schools like Dover who are
demonstrating that the amount of money
that's coming from the state is not
enough to provide those Services we have
that continued downshifting to local
taxpayers it has negative effects on
students like my son who didn't have the
ability to receive those services for
two years in a row it's getting better
now for him thankfully he's a freshman
now and he's really thriving at over
high school but it was really rough in
those mid years and it would have been
rougher if his disabilities required him
to receive out of District placements
which as we know regularly cost six
figures a year thank you for the
question thank you thank you uh I'd like
to call Gabriel Jetty and Then followed
sanago and did we have Brenda Quinn yeah
Brenda come on up and then uh Gabriel
Jetty then Wendy
Santiago thank you honorable repres
resentatives for hearing my thoughts um
I will say I've heard a lot about the
financial and I was actually going to to
say some focus on the financial and that
there's uh Financial irresponsibility in
in um a program that is for the Merit of
children and I I'm a mental health
professional I've worked primarily with
children for 36 years and um care very
deeply about their well-being so I want
Choice I'm I'm a New Hampshire resident
from birth I like Choice um but I also
understand that the lack of
accountability um for any programming
outside of the public school district is
very dangerous um for the young people
that I see I also want to just speak to
a couple things that were were stated
one that choice is an important thing um
for young people I think public schools
are an important thing for young people
and if you look at the developmental
task of young people through grade
school through high school um
generalization is incredibly important
and meaning that sitting next to
somebody with a different opinion a
different background different needs uh
is imperative to healthy development and
public schools offer that it is not for
everybody I understand but those who
fiscally can decide to be elsewhere can
do so this expansion speaks to making
this available to people who could
already afford to make that choice and
the voucher as it stands now allows for
people who can't to to have their needs
met but I do think that I would much
rather see for the well-being of the
many kids that I've seen through my my
practice that the public schools get
more of the attention that they need and
that special education needs get better
addressed as they were back when I
worked with the area agencies in my
first nine professional years um
integrating kids into schools we are not
adequately nor fairly funding those and
I understand there's a plan available to
do that um I would rather have our
energies put there than expanding a
voucher program that does not assure or
even um offer any kind of accountability
and does offer an increase in taxes that
are going to harm so many people who
want to stay in their homes and stay in
their towns and stay in their
communities that are largely built
around healthy Public School Systems
thank you thank you very much any
questions thank you uh so we have is
Gabriel Jetty
[Music]
here
right come on
[Music]
okay okay sorry we're just your yeah um
awesome and I'm assuming it's about two
minutes right I'll just keep my ey yes
it is okay thank you um hi good
afternoon I first just want to thank the
committee for listening to public
testimony on this bill my name is
Gabriel Jetty and I am here today to ask
for your support of
hb15 um I am a born and raised New
Hampshire citizen I've been here my
whole life um my husband and I have
three children two of them are with me
um and the ages are 6 4 and 1 this is
Henry and Gracie um and as a mother I
want to I want to and I try to give my
children the best opportunities for them
and the ways that fit their individual
needs because of this we have enrolled
our children at St Francis School in
Lichfield we're we live in Manchester
but it's very close to us um we could
not be happier with the education that
they have received so far Henry right
here has gone from having problems with
letter recognition to reading and just a
few short months um they have natural
science classes in the woods they have a
little farm with sheep and chickens that
the children help out with um so it's
just a really holistic education and we
really really loved it um they also have
very small teacher to student ratios
which allows for more of that
individualized learning which has very
um very much benefited Henry as
well um but we like many other families
sit just above the income limit to
qualify for the EFA benefit um now
because because of this we do pay out of
pocket for all of the children's
education expenses and we are able to
make it work but it's not easy it is
difficult every single month my husband
and I are budgeting to make sure like
where can we cut things because the
education is expensive um now again as a
mother we want to give them the best
opportunities so we make those
sacrifices but uh expanding this bill it
would really help families like mine
with three and four plus children many
of them at St Francis as well who again
sit just above the income limit but
because they have larger families they
have a lot larger expenses to take care
of as well um so anyways I'm here again
to ask for you to support this bill um
because it's really helped the school
that our children go to has been
wonderful and beautiful and we would
just love to see that for every student
thank you thank you very
much questions from the committee thank
you for coming today it's thank you with
two youngsters thank you appreciate it
uh next person is Wendy San Diego
ski I guess I can these down here
so thank you for allowing me to speak
today um what I'm going to speak about
is moral could you please start by you
know explaining who you are so everyone
else can hear it yes sir um I'm my name
is Wendy Santiago and I am a recipient
of the
EFA um and so I represent my family and
I'm going to talk about the story about
my son and how we came about
EFA through um the
program
so
my family should be began started
receiving the EFA approxim about five
years ago before this program my son had
been in a school where he had been
significantly bullied including being
taunted verbally
threatened um insulted and physically
harmed he would come home with ripped
pants and severely bodily injuries that
needed medical attention from both his
primary care office as well as
Specialists such as
Orthopedics
um unfortunately the schools turned
their Blind Eye to the
situation this is a public
school causing causing it to um continue
that my son my son's um accelerated
academics declined significantly and he
became afraid to attend school in turn I
needed I had to choose to homeschool him
for the rest of that year this incident
alarmed if my son had had this same
violent harassment and any other
location other than a
school the individual's actions would
violate the New Hampshire harassment
laws outlined in RSA 4
6444 which supports to protect citizens
offenses now that we have the EFA my son
who sits next to me has been
flourishing um significant not only can
I yes not only in his education but in
his self-esteem and confidence he is 16
years old he is a full-time college
student he just inured his first job and
he's also a student pilot
so if it had not been for this program
my this would not have been available
for if you have more now Noah also
completed a card here so he's entitled
at 2 minutes as well okay uh so are you
on Noah's time right now
um he can
speak uh hello everyone I don't exactly
know what to say but
well I did have something planned I just
thought so this I don't um what speak
what you were talking I don't know
what okay um
so basically
um everybody has a right to have School
rights my son is just a small is just
one person out of many we just heard
testimonies of children being sexually
assaulted sexually
harassed in the school
systems everybody has a right to be free
from those things but there are
but if all families just took their kids
out of school to homeschool them we
wouldn't have families
working so unfortunately it is necessary
to have a program like
EFA to support the needs of these
children who seek alternative schooling
so they can avoid being abused at school
I my son would like to finish so I
remember that one of the main arguments
against this bill is that it provides
much funding to Christian and other
religious institutions and while the
Constitution does say that Congress and
well any laog making people can't
specifically support one religion the
EFA program doesn't specifically support
only Christians it's it can go to anyone
if a Jewish person wanted to go to a
Jewish school then they can go there
same with the Buddhist they any anyone
else and also with the public schools
another big point was that the private
schools don't perform as well as public
schools which to me that doesn't make
any sense because that my brief time in
opposite if okay
yeah thank you thank you very
much thank you very much both of you
thank you you're
welcome I
Michelle pardon me are there any
questions any questions Yeah Yeah
question yes go ahead I just want to say
when thank you you're very
welcome thank you can I get your name
please myself no we got no right oh y
thank you welcome Michelle Sarah wingren
followed by Ronnie grubber or
Grover yeah grro
good um I'm Sarah Wen and I'm 10 years
old I used to go to public school but am
now going to private school when I was
in public school there were after school
activities but as I went further into my
education things were getting cut off
starting with these actor school
activities then the foreign languages
were
gone just before I got into Middle
School the school didn't have the budget
to pay the teacher anymore we need
teachers to help with what we're
struggling with or to go beyond the
curriculum when we're ready there's only
one music teacher to teach grades K
eight the money that you would want to
send to families going to private school
could be helping Public Schools ac
across the state um have opportunities
for students to learn what they love in
the towns they live in in conclusion
this money is better spent on public
schools to help students prepare for
careers thank you honorable chair and
members of the committee um and thank
you Sarah for testifying today so I am
testif in today in support of a choice I
am asking for a choice for that that I'm
asking you to allow parents to make a
choice to send their kids to Quality
resourced public schools in the
communities that they live in as you
heard as my daughter has progressed
through schools um because of the
choices that this legislature and the
towns have made to reduce funding to the
public
schools these students have diminished
opportunities at every turn and over the
past couple of years I've engaged in a
significant amount of Schoolboard
advocacy to bring these opportunities
back but there just isn't any local
money to bring them back with and so in
the end we made a very difficult choice
to send our child to private school last
year um both of our children and it was
hard it was very hard we had to make
Cuts we are not going to remodel the
basement that we had planned to do we
are not um we are not have the savings
that we wanted to have we don't can I
talked take take another minute okay
thank you we um my personal sting is
that I don't have my ski passes anymore
but in the end last year um we went to
the annual meeting and at the annual
meeting the fight was not about what
programs we could bring back to the
school it was whether or not we could
fix the leaking moldy windows in the
building these are the choices that the
schools have to make and so I'm asking
you today to make a choice I'm asking
you to fund public schools and make sure
that students have quality schools in
their local communities so we don't have
to drive 35 minutes out of our way to
access a quality public a quality school
um or I'm asking you to make a choice to
spend public money to make sure that
people like me who choose private
education can afford ski passes in
addition to that private education I
think the choice here is clear on where
your public money is best spent thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee Sarah did
you type all that up yourself on that
report I did um but then my mom did help
me a little bit with the editing but it
was mostly me very good job
congratulations to both of you thank you
uh Ronnie Grover and Donna chick is
following
Ronnie hello I am Ronnie's mom my name
is Amanda Quint qu i n
c um this is Ronnie he is 11 years old
and he has been participating in EFA for
about two years Ronnie was in public
school for seven years we live in
Kingston um he started when he was three
in
preschool he got diagnosed with high
functioning autism and sensory
processing now throughout school he
always had a difficult
time with the surrounding the the noise
the lights um so even though he was
having a tough time I still pushed him
to go um fast forward a couple years he
was being bullied at school um kids were
not being nice to him in the school
district would not do what he needed to
make him feel comfortable and safe at
school which to me does not is not right
that's not right every child should feel
feel safe at public school and if they
don't they definitely should be able to
receive EFA funds now the EFA funds are
less than
$5,000 for a school year that is not
anywhere near what a private school
costs so if I was right now we are
homeschooling so we don't have any extra
money for any anything out of the
ordinary we barely can get food on the
table but that money from EFA helps him
feel comfortable learning and feeling
safe at the same time all children
should be able to feel safe while they
get an
education may I speak real
quick um just a second I I want to make
sure that people are speaking do have
pink cards yes go ahead
okay
um EFA has helped me through a lot um if
it wasn't for it I would not have all
the supplies that I have to do and get a
deserves great job any questions any
questions not seeing any thank you very
much thank you both for coming you're
welcome uh so is Donna
Austin now before we start the kids are
time I got Donna right here we're
looking
[Music]
ahead hi I'm happy to have this
opportunity to speak with you my name is
Haley Cajun I'm 13 years old I live in
oopy I'd like to start off with I have
been in and out of the foster care
system a few times involving two
different states
because of that not only were my
academics low but my G my grades kept
dropping in my prior educational
settings I started to project an image
of myself that really wasn't me I was
frustrated and I felt lost with my life
my family and I decided that home school
was best for me with the help of EFA we
have been able to hire a tutor my grades
are not perfect but they're all in their
way and I now able to take lessons for
dance which has helped me get out more
and build my self-esteem EFA has given
me an environment to learn and to be
successful in my education but I do fear
that if we no longer qualify for EFA
funding my family would not be able to
offer the education that fits me best my
parents have worked hard to straighten
their life out for the best it would
hurt me and them to see a piece of that
hard work dug out and thrown away please
guarantee EFA will be available
thank
you I should be within the two minutes
but I might still 34
seconds thank you for the opportunity to
speak my name is Donna and I'm from oopi
my husband and I have fostered over 17
children and we have 12 adopted children
if learning From The Trenches qualifies
a person as an expert then in the field
of helping and caring for children I
hold that title I have been a
homeschooling mom for more than 24 years
and I've seen my homeschool children
succeed in their chosen Fields beside me
are some of my grandchildren I'd like to
focus on one of these great kids for a
moment 20 months ago at the age of 8 and
a
half oh that must be her time 20 months
ago at the age of eight and a half my
grandson could not identify numbers 1 to
10 he didn't know his alphabet nor could
he write his name due to his parents'
drug use he had only sporadically
attended Public School upon taking
guardianship our immediate task was to
educate him we've utilized tutors and
one-on-one homeschool instruction he's
here today so we can put a face on
educational Freedom the thought that a
financial cap could deny this child all
the advantages he needs to catch up and
succeed in his education should hit
Accord with each and every one of you
sitting in front of me some of my
grandkids were in and out of foster care
the end story is a happy one as that my
daughter and her husband were reunited
with their children 3 years ago but
along with the educa but along with the
emotional toll these children paid their
education also suffered public school
isn't working for them private school
isn't working for them their parents
recently brought them home to learn in
the security of their home where the
closeness of family creates a safe
learning environment for them a cap on
that's we're I'd like you to just take a
minute look at these children and let
them be the face of educational Freedom
this program should be open to all
children so that they all have the same
opportunities as my grandchildren and I
thank you very much thank you thank you
are there any questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
you it over thank you
thank you for all your
work uh
Alyssa Sosa
Molina and followed
Jr then I think we're done the parents
yeah
yeah yeah I got to get them
too see Hi H
Austin these are my three kids uh Lucy
Fiona and
Xander um I attended on public school
for my kids um each of them have special
needs and so when I was told by
worldclass experts I'm talking doctors
from Boston and even doctors Boston had
blown in and I saw Specialists when they
said your kids need this and this will
be uh needed for school I thought it
would be really easy um I also have a
niece that I helped raise and four times
I have been sat across from public
school Educators and been told that they
do not want to follow the educational
and even the physical safety plans for
my children so my intention was always
to public school but it did not work for
us um we have found the solution in
going private we have uh PT OT uh we
have neurology from Boston and many
others the EPA allows us to make a
positive Choice uh for my niece this a
private school for my eldest she's in a
private learning program um for my
middle and homeschool is homeschooling
and for my youngest when he ages into
the program in the fall um it's going to
be working with um private OT and PT
Specialists to help him work on the
skills he needs to catch up with his
peers and just to let you guys know I've
heard that the money is not tracked
actually every last every last penny
spent by parents or schools on the EPA
program is on the children's scholarship
phone website um
and income levels shouldn't be a factor
the parents who have millions are not
going to bother with the paperwork
necessary because there is a lot of
paperwork for parents um and those who
are on the edge who need this money will
be able to access it they should not
have to decide between a um working two
jobs to make sure their kids get what
they need and having the money for to
send their kids where they believe that
their kids do best um please give all
the um kids in this state whose parents
are on that cusp the opportunity to get
the help they
need thank you very much I saw the young
one coming down the hallway look at he
split yeah he is very capable and he's
very capable it's mostly due to the fact
that we are able to access um private PT
the school actually um said that their
primary goal was to get him walking
despite the fact that Boston children
said his primary goal is mobility um so
it's been a long fight with a lot of
different people I want to be able to
access this for my children are there
any questions from the
committee thank you very much for coming
today
um are there any other children I mean
young ones here I Heard a Voice back in
the
corner
um pardon
me yeah and we had uh Daryl Hall yeah
corner good afternoon good afternoon
darl my name is Daryl Hall I'm here with
my family um we have three children
Olivia Sophia and Logan age 98 and
four thank you for allowing me to read
my testimony in 2021 we moved to pelum
New Hampshire and enrolled our kids in
the school system in 2023 the elementary
school failed Us by lacking quality
education inadequate disciplinary Pro
policies and pushing disagreeable social
agendas the following year we embarked
on a personalized attentive and
homebased education program for our
children and all three have surpassed
metrics from their public school
education according to town reports
enrollment in the pelum school district
has an average has had an average 3%
decline over the past 5 Years From 2019
to 2023 yet is an average 65% of total
taxes according to the New Hampshire
Department of Education I achieved data
for the same period students had an
average English language arts Ela and
math proficiency rate of 51% and 41%
respectively their proficiency numbers
fail to meet the state targets each year
suffice to say we have no intention to
reenroll our children into the public
school system unless those shortcomings
are remedied to a satisfactory level
these unfortunate circumstances leave
parents to choose between a poor public
school education or taking on the
financial burden just to give their kids
at least a decent private
education at the end of the day it is
always in the best interest of our
children to choose the method of
Education that best prepares them for
life with the values of our family so my
statement to those who oppose this bill
is this as a family on the mass border
where cost of living is high my and
other children in our community are
being denied resources because of your
perception of what success should look
like an EFA would help lessen the burden
of providing a better education for our
children by opening access to additional
thank you very much thank you any
questions any questions yes
representative thank you for coming and
thank you for your testimony and and I
recognize Bo is one of the is the
headline schools in this state and
you're talking about having to face
disagreeable social agendas
uh was there any way for you to hold it
to address this with them oneon-one and
and just have a conversation with them
explaining to them what the nature of
that was and why it was so disagreeable
or did they just shut you
off well there's there wasn't really any
one specific instance it was a a
culmination of social agendas that don't
don't fit with our family values did
they have these in writing excuse me
there your multiple questions over there
sorry I'm sorry if there's a form for me
to express those concerns with the
public school system I'm happy to do it
um but just an atmosphere of social
agenda being pushed in the school system
um made us choose to homeschool our
children okay we want to stay right on
115 yeah yeah excuse me and Mr chair
just for the record that was what what
school were you talking about Helm New
Hampshire not
Bo yeah okay so thank you for the
clarity um the
corner we had children we have children
all kinds of angles here um and a lot of
cards um I want to get the real you're
holding children back there do you want
to speak right now or were you did I
call somebody else prior to that I don't
think I have because those are Daryl's
kids over there right yes okay all right
thank you very much Daryl thank you so
that's just a new one
okay we need your name so we can get the
card sure it's Jessica Mig pardon me Mig
M
L and I am here in support of the bill
and um I am not a recipient of the EFA
because I I lie my husband and I lie
just above that um income um bracket
where we would be able to apply for it
and as a result we um we've had to make
great sacrifices uh the only reason why
we're here today is because my children
had dentist appointments trying to put
them back into school at noon time is a
nightmare so we are able to to be here
um and I I wanted to speak today to say
that uh the if even if we could get a
little bit of support uh financially to
send our kids to a school that supports
uh what our family values are uh it
would change our um it would change the
mindset for my husband and I we live
just above that line and my husband
works in sales one more dip of the
economy um and it wouldn't just be our
kids education it would be a whole lot
more we Pro we live in Dober New
Hampshire um rent in do New Hampshire um
runs
about let's just say I barely can afford
my rent I'll leave it at that and uh
should something happened and we
wouldn't be able to do that not only
would we um potentially lose our kids
education in the school and there uh he
go he's four she's uh Isabelle is five
we would not only lose their school but
we'd probably have to leave the town and
go to a different school and this also
presents an issue for us where our kids
are established um and so just having
the freedom of education for our kids is
is everything um I understand that
public schools need funding too but when
it comes to uh my kids and our our
community around us uh having um an
education that not only backs up what we
what our family believes but also like
the values of the kids that um our kids
are in school with and spending a lot of
time with that's it thank you very much
committee good luck down there in
do thank you very
the card
enough that's okay we got your card
okay hello my name is Alysa s Molina I'm
here today to ask you to support house
built age 115 I'm a senior in high
school who has been receiving the
education Freedom funds for over four
years now I grew up being homeschooled
by my single mom until I was of high
school age I wanted to seek out new
better opportunities and try new things
for the last 3 years I have been
attending a private school that has
afforded me much growth
opportunities and a brighter future I
would be in a very different situation
right now without the EFA just this
recent year I can tell you a very dear
and close friend of mine was being
bullied at her school it was drastically
hurting her and her life she needed a
change a new school she couldn't go on
in this same environment she's now at an
amazing school but that wouldn't have
been possible without the FAA I ask you
to please take a moment to think about
someone you know someone you love who
has been bullied stuck in a toxic
environment or maybe they would be stuck
at a level unable to reach their full
potential when they could be exceling in
things they're naturally gifted in
perhaps like mathematics or history or
maybe they would be even worse
experiencing the oposite academically
challenged struggling to keep up with
everyone else their confidence and
selfworth being torn down leaving them
questioning wondering why can't I be
like everyone else when they would be
excelling if they could receive the help
they needed think of these kids please
who are at a disposition in their life
that is entirely out of their control
they didn't get to choose their family's
incomes where they were born or how
others would treat them sadly there are
hundreds of kids like this in New
Hampshire who face these realities daily
the fa has started this positive change
for these kids like me to have better
growth opportunities and achievement to
attain a better life they deserve I
would know as I'm one of them by passing
this bill you would be making the EFA
more accessible to all regardless of
their income giving these kids and their
families a chance to attain a life they
deserve wouldn't you want that if it
were your child so I implore you to
please be part of these change to give
these kids opportunities which in turn
create a better future and help them
create a better life thank you very much
because just as Nelson Mandel said
education is the most powerful weapon
which you can use to change the world
these kids are counting on you so please
vote in support for hp15 today thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee thank you very much our
thank you Mr chairman long long time no
see haven't seen you in a while good to
be here my name is Mark Malone I
represent the town of eping Rockingham
District 5 and I'm here I'm not here
against uh educational Freedom acts uh
accounts what I am here as a c capacity
is also as the vice chair of the eping
budget committee
and as it right now my opposition to
this bill is based on the fact
that family who wants to send their
child to Philips exer Academy which has
a tuition of
$52,599 plus $900 for supplies can get
an education Freedom
account right is that
correct There's No
Limit now I don't know how many people
will actually do this but to think think
about the numbers of families out there
who can send their child it's a day this
is for the day student by the way so
somebody living in New Hampshire could
likely apply for that as a member of the
budget Committee in eping I find that
outrageous that the taxpayers of eping
and I walked around last fall
campaigning to mobile homes Shacks where
people were struggling to pay their
property tax that we're going to spend
taxpayer dollars to fund someone
to go to Philips xer Academy with the
tuition is
$53,000 now somebody wrote that local
districts spend I think like drunken
Sailors I think I've read that
someplace what is it if we open the
accounts to anyone regardless of
income how much money are we going to be
spending here how much are the taxpayers
of eping going to be spending to
subsidize people now the folks who are
here who are struggling I see the need
for the EFA accounts I see that but we
have a cap and it's means tested you
want to take away means testing you are
taking
away the the ability of weing taxpayers
to fund adequately public education for
the children who don't take
efas so again think about that that you
are just opening it's a Pandora's Box
that you are opening with no limits
thank you thank you very much
representative any questions for the
representative yes representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much representative palone and for
uh testifying here this afternoon and
also for your service on the eping um
budget committee so um there's been a
lot of um recent news I think related to
um some information released by the
Department of Education New Hampshire
Department of Education in the last
several days with respect to the amount
of of state do that support public
school districts but uh but one of the
things they haven't released uh publicly
is the fact that across all the
245 uh districts um in the state that
I'm sorry uh T municipalities in the
state that um that only a hundred of
them received more State Grant and 145
of them their state Grant went down in
many cases very significantly um as a
member of the budget committee uh you're
probably aware then next year that
eeping state Grant is scheduled to go
down
right right what does that mean for
eping well somebody's got to pay for the
schools so either so either um we're
going to raise taxes and that was I mean
we are very aware and eing about the tax
rate and about the implication of
votings and we had our public hearings
both on the town and the school budgets
last night
and you know it's not pretty looking at
that we we have pushed back on school
and town uh spending but at the same
time we're looking at to try to keep
teachers contract for example is coming
out it's going to be $400,000 warrant
article
$400,000 that money is going to increase
the tax rate so I am just wondering if
we're going to be able to pass that and
if we don't pass it then we saw what
happened the last time eping didn't pass
the teachers contract the district lost
a number of really good teachers this is
what happen when we don't adequately
fund our public educations
which educate the vast majority of
students in this state got to keep that
in
mind so we want to spend taxpayer
dollars so some child can go to Philips
Seer Academy with a subsidy now it
doesn't pay the whole
tuition but there's no reason why those
that family couldn't apply for it and no
reason why they won't get it
you have no controls on this Bill thank
you very much representative further
questions thank you I'd like to call Jen
Bean thank you I appreciate you taking
me I have a basketball game with my kids
to get to yeah basketball is important
stuff yeah um good afternoon um my name
is Jennifer black I live in Windham I'm
speaking in favor of HB 115 around the
time my son was born 22 years ago I
spoke to a neighbor who was a long time
public school teacher in one of the
local
schools she lamented the behavior of
students and how hard it was to teach
she described the CL classroom as
chaotic as teachers were not allowed to
discipline students concerned about my
children's future education I dealt
further I asked her if she was able to
call their parents when they misbehaved
she says teachers do not want to deal
with parents at all because they don't
believe their child is ever at fault I
asked what about parents who want to
hold their children accountable and what
want to make sure their child is
behaving she said we don't want to deal
with parents at all we just direct
parents to the principal my husband and
I as as parents of six children did not
want our kids teachers to think of us as
the enemy we feel it is our
responsibility to see to it that our
children are raised and properly
educated in order to be independent
God-fearing responsible contributing
members of society after discussion with
this teacher hearing stories from other
parents and reading up on the state of
public education in America my husband
and I decided that I would give up my
well-paying job so I could stay home and
raise and educate our
children I homeschooled for several
years but when my kids started becoming
interested in sports and other
activities we looked at affordable
private options they were few and far
between with six children we found a
small Christian School and after talking
to parents and teachers we grateful to
hear that parents and teachers were
collaborators not enemies in the
education process that children are not
permitted to disrupt classes and that
students are well educated in math
reading grammar Science and
History parents who determine that his
best interest for their children and for
society in general that their children
be educated outside the chaos of the
local public school have to make many
sacrifices to afford the both the taxes
that they pay for the public schools
their children do not attend and the
tuition for the school that they have
decided is best for their children
although we have never purchased a new
car never gone on extravagant vacations
never taken our kids on an airplane our
children have benefited greatly from our
choice to avoid public school and we do
not regret our decision one bit
unfortunately there are many other
parents who' like to be able to make
this decision but can't afford to make
the necessary
sacrifices I uh I would like to submit
that you support hb15 and I have thank
you very much thank you uh roofa Bean
name yeah I'm trying to the next person
up be Gian Gallery g l l e gy e y
needed old manuscript zor blower the
Palmer method all
Giana who do we have
here
me thank you I'm chela
so I'm Gian jel at resident of Madbury I
have two children in public schools and
I'm a school board member on the oyer
river Cooperative School District sa5 I
am here representing the school board of
w r people move to our district because
of the public school system we oppose
hb15 I've heard many people today speak
to educational attainment and access and
the lack thereof the best most fiscal
responsible most Equitable way to ensure
that all students in New Hampshire
access and achieve the best education
possible is to fully fund public
education vouchers efas do not ensure
Equity because even with Aid many if not
most families cannot afford the cost of
private or parial education this bill
does not affect that fact because it
expands access to the higher income as
opposed to lower income folks this is
quite evident by who is already
receiving the vouchers which is
approximately 75% of families who have
never attended Public School vouchers
are not fiscally responsible and this
expansion would make it even more so
their expansion negatively affects the
School District budget and therefore
services and program the schools are
legally mandated to provide in order to
maintain and Achieve high standards the
funding shortfall must be addressed
which typically translates to
unsustainable increases in property
taxes and unfortunately cuts to services
this negative fiscal impact is
particularly relevant in light of
projected budget shortfalls but also due
to the current Court declared inadequate
funding for public education overall and
those court cases are still still
standing and the massive Gap in
reimbursement for special education
which is particularly affecting our
district
public education covers and accepts all
students private and parial students
schools do not Public Schools must
accept special education students and
are proud to do so but private schools
do not and therefore do not show the
cost the vast majority of students in
Hampshire attend public schools the
voucher program is also deeply
problematic due to its lack of
accountability oversight and standards
the out ofst State organization running
it has done such a poor oversight that
an audit of a small sub sample show that
25% of the families enrolled should not
have been public education however is
very transparent accountable and has
many legally mandated constraints and
responsibilities in light of all these
things I I ask you to oppose
hb15 thank you very much questions from
the committee yes representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
your work on behalf of public schools
could you speak about your District's um
parents we have a pretty good access to
that we have rules where um if a teacher
if a if a parent actually emails a
student they have to respond uh if a
parent emails a teacher they have to
respond within 48 Hours um so
immediately they have to have that if
that doesn't happen then it immediately
goes to the principal and the people
have access to that um communication our
school district is actually very good
people can email they can call they can
they can visit and um there's typically
not a problem with that it's very open
access people attend the school board
meetings one of the things I think is
actually a strength with oyer river is
the fact that the community is actually
very active and if they have a problem
they N US snow immediately so I actually
say the communication is quite excellent
thank you thank you very
much thank you very much for coming
today represent Bob
warry needs to pick up children by three
o'clock you're just about ready to miss
that
date followed by representative
Alexander
thank you Mr chair and honorable members
of the committee for the record my name
is Bob worry and I represent Hillsboro
District 13 the great town of Hudson
education in New Hampshire is facing the
challenge of economic efficiency an
increasing amount of money is being
requested and spent while enrollment is
sharply declining and yet educational
proficiency is also declining from a
business perspective one might say we
are simply not achieving the desired
return on investment what are we to do
it is time for New Hampshire to have
Universal educational Freedom accounts
in support of universal efas I would
like to first talk about making quality
education options more attainable though
many communities offer an adequate
education not all communities offer the
quality education desired by the parents
and custodians that meet the unique
needs of their child or children as
we've heard from several testimonies
already suppose you have a student
facing challenges not being met by a
local school or you have a gifted
student
what are the options if a local school
is not providing education at this
quality level desired by the parent or
Guardian there are limited options
available and these educational
opportunities would be made more
feasible and more attainable with
universal
efas next I would like to talk about
accountability and local control for the
money being spent on students education
currently parents and custodians using
the efas have greater accountability
than any school administrative unit has
first each EFA applicant has their
financial status verified and grants are
then prated accordingly then every item
requested for reimbursement is reviewed
by the EFA special program before the
EFA funds are dispersed for
reimbursement each request is reviewed
and substantiated I support Universal
efas because efas inherently provide
more direct accountability for the money
that is being spent through Universal
efas we can give households greater
control of a relatively small part of
the total money being spent on their
students education it is the ultimate in
local control lastly I would like to
emphasize something mentioned earlier
return on investment Universal efas
allow for parents and Guardians to make
that direct investment into their
student whether it is tuition tutoring
online learning school supplies or other
Scholastic expenses Universal efas will
give more options and provide for
enhanced accountability for investing in
their students the students in New
Hampshire will be found very capable of
given the right resources and additional
opportunities Universal efas are a good
investment in the students of New
Hampshire in the interest of time in
picking up my own child from school I
will not be taking any questions oh
thank you and if you have a you know
written comment why don't you submit
that to us too or from the portal or
wherever I I I will thank you very much
uh representative Joe Alexander then
thank you chairman lad and members of
House Education funding for the record
my name is Joe Alexander I represent the
town of gown um I'm here today as a
proud product of New Hampshire schools
but my story today is not about
education I received it's about the
importance of giving every child the
opportunity to find a school that fits
their educational individual needs
whether academic social or emotional as
a young man I struggled with my identity
I spent years coming to terms with being
gay but my experience in school wasn't
always easy I wasn't always comfortable
with my
surroundings or the people I interacted
with which made it harder for me to D
Thrive I'm proud of how far our
community has come since then how much
more accepting and supportive it has
become for individuals like myself but
not every child today feels the same
comfort and security for some students
finding a school environment that
Embraces them is not just important it's
critical I fundamentally believe that we
need to invest in families if the school
is not providing a good product for a
family the state should invest those
funds out elsewhere I do not want any
student to feel like the bullied gay
child trapped in a school with no way
out this bill is about educational
Freedom it's about ensuring that every
child no matter their situation has a
chance to find the school that's the
best fit for them that's why I'm proud
to co-sponsor
hb15 and I hope all of you will join me
in voting for it thank you thank you
very much other questions from the
committee not see you thank you very
much uh Mary
wilky followed by
Megan d
e i no should be Davis Davis or I don't
got gota take care of
conquered welcome Mary thank you um
thank you for calling me up and U my
name is Mary wilky I'm a retired public
school teacher from conquer and I oppose
this bill uh first of all any expansion
of this program whether to Universal
eligibility or to 500% of federal
federal poverty guidelines which would
be about
$161,000 uh for a family of four would
mean more public money taken away from
our community Public Schools where
nearly 90% of our children in New
Hampshire attend um we have parents in
communities throughout this state who
love their Public Schools but they're
upset about how teacher turnover or lack
of foreign languages or art uh classes
or the state of disrepair of their
buildings um in other words reduced
opportunities that their children face
because they happen to live in the wrong
ZIP code all too often we hear of
elderly people being forced out of their
homes because they can't pay their
property taxes and that's because uh
monies that the state is supposed to be
providing or being downshifted onto the
property taxpayers we also have a
serious Revenue uh deficit looming ahead
and the prospect of big budget cuts so
this doesn't seem to be the right time
to expand this program by giving money
to even more parents who are probably
already affording private schools on
their own as have 80% of the people who
are currently receiving
vouchers um I'm also concerned about
good stewardship requires uh getting
good answers to questions before
expanding a program we don't even know
if the $73 million that's been spent on
this program has had a positive or
negative impact on student outcomes we
don't have any data here to tell us but
in uh reports from other states show
that voucher programs are leading to
lower academic achievement in part
because many of the providers that
spring up in response to voucher
programs are of poor quality uh to what
extent our vouchers simply replacing
scholarships that the schools were
providing before which would mean we're
enriching the schools not the and the
families come out with no net benefit
financially um I have a number of other
concerns which I feel ought to be
addressed before you expand the program
and I feel you ought to know we all
ought to know and they're on my written
testimony which I will hand in and thank
you very much thank you very much
questions from the committee thank you
again um Megan
Davis is she
back I think she was putting money in a
meter and
Amy
okay yeah and then we'll and then we'll
have
uh uh Megan if she's back yet from the
okay hello Amy Hansen I live in Amhurst
I I'm here to express my strong
opposition to the proposal for Universal
eligibility for the EFA program in New
Hampshire while I understand the desire
to provide more educational options for
families there are serious concerns
about extending the program to All
Families regardless of income level or
specific need one little sentence being
omitted from the original Law is a huge
impact one undermining public education
Public Schools serve as a foundation for
education for the majority of our
students in New Hampshire and would harm
lowincome and vulnerable students who
rely on public education for quality and
Equitable learning
experience Equity issues lower-income
families may still face challenges
accessing private educational options
even with EFA expansion The Divide this
divides rather than helps level the
playing field by discounting families
who can pay the tuition regardless of
the
vouchers selective enrollment private
religious schools can also pick who they
choose to come to their schools and that
changes the playing field as well as
some of the people who would benefit
from it might not even have the option
to go to those places accountability and
oversight public schools are held to
rigorous standards assessments
curriculum regulations and also hiring
requirements based on certifications but
private schools are not always subject
to the same scrutiny leaving students
without the protections and supports
they need to Su succeed like I APS and
504s increased financial burden the cost
of funding such program for every
student could lead to higher taxes or
Cuts other essential services such as
education for all separation of church
and state tax dollars should not be used
for any religious entity expanding EFA
to all students without addressing these
broader concerns could have unintended
negative consequences for both public
education and students it serves there
is currently systems in place for our
students who require out of District
place
we should use those thank you for your
you uh next person up would be is she
back yet from the
Joseph uh yes I restate my name Joe coll
I'm from Portsmouth um and thanks for
having the open hearing um you know
there's a lot of feeling about how
Choice has been so helpful to people but
the bill isn't about choice for what
kind of education to get the bill is
about whether the public should pay for
that this the bill is is proposes that
the public the taxpayers in New
Hampshire pays for that choice and
there's been a that this whole thing
about vouer programs in the last couple
decades has been an aema to everything
that came prior to that before
everything that came prior to that the
public paid for public
education and what's been going on the
last couple of decades is Public Funding
has been cut and cut again and then
there's you know people need help with
vouchers so it it's it's not it's it's
radical and it's not
traditional
um the um there's a lot of things that
are not conservative about this this
kind of a program one of the things is
it undercuts local autonomy you know you
have a lot of people in New Hampshire I
don't know how many hundreds of people
in New Hampshire give so much of their
time to Schoolboard service and all that
sort of thing and basically what it's
telling them is look you know we're
going to take money from the public
system and fund private system so it's
undercutting all the efforts that
individual people are putting into the
school
systems
so the other big thing about I I got to
speak what's good about Public School
Systems I'm I'm I'm I'm a child of
immigrants and I went to a public school
where I was extreme low minority um one
of the things it does is it is it um
okay it's uh it works against The Silo
the problem you know we all live in
silos now it's it's a horrible problem
you know people don't talk to each other
they don't relate to anybody that thinks
differently than them opposite to come
different different cultural backgrounds
and everybody everybody every kid in
school has to go to school together and
having that experience I think made a
huge difference in my life because I got
expand expanded to a lot of white white
people and it made it I think it makes a
lot a big difference to a lot of kids so
I'm here to speak for the for public
schools and against the Bill thank you
very much Joseph are there any
questions thank you very much thanks for
coming
up uh uh Megan Davis is
back and followed by um hope vanan EPS
Epp
s and then uh representative cordelli
Will Follow
That hi uh my name is Megan Davis I am a
recipient of the EFA my daughter gets it
um she's been at a wonderful School a
Dublin Christian and I have no money to
send her there so without the EFA she
would not be there and they have very
high standards at Dublin uh her she was
reading in kindergarten and now she's
reading uh chapter books in second grade
and uh you know I'm really grateful for
the EFA because she not only can go to
Dublin
Christian but I can also sent her to
gymnastics too so the $5,000 covers
uh even more than gymnastics and Dublin
Christian so I mean it's a great thing
for people in New Hampshire and you know
um my uh I come from a middle inome
middle inome family upper middle income
uh so like $200,000 my dad makes and we
have three kids in our family and I
don't think you know he struggled at
times to send us to private school
occasionally
and it was uh very difficult for my
family to do so but when we were in a
district that had bad schools that's
what he did but then later he went to
you know send us to college and that was
just incredibly hard for him so you know
you don't get to save any money uh for
your kids college education if you're
putting that into private school and so
it's very very bad uh very very
difficult for parents to send their kids
to private school um also
uh you know I think that's all that I
wanted to say you know also I I I find
that I've been researching uh the spike
of
transgenderism okay uh just this one
last thing is that
um the Gen ZZ uh population is
their their um transgenderism went up
by uh
400% in 10 years I I think we're getting
off topic now well that it's not safe
you're Bey on your time limit as well
okay thank you very very much uh hope
Spencer yes
uh I'm
here she's right yeah go ahead good
afternoon my name is Hope vaps and I
represent myself here today as a mother
of three and former Portsmith School
Board member that manage School budgets
I support public schools that educate
the majority of our students while not a
perfect system it is the system that
levels the playing field and offers an
education to all children regardless of
race religion gender and economic status
public schools are also a Haven for much
needed social services that fall short
in communities today the pandemic
magnified how much the public relies on
public school social resources
addressing bullying it can happen
everywhere for my child it happened in
private school before moving to the
local public schools we found Public
School staff uniquely qualified to
address the diverse academic social and
emotional needs of students regardless
of their
backgrounds while Alternative Learning
options profile student acceptance
Public Schools accepts everyone and
equip students to contribute in a
diverse
Society the charge on public schools cut
budgets that help close pandemic
learning gaps take funds from mandated
specialed programs and Rob students of
an adequate education the voucher
program divies up the limited funds the
state provides and makes it impossible
for school boards and
municipalities to budget and provide
adequate education for their own Local
Schools without depending on local State
dollars the imperfections the opposition
speak of will not improve with defunding
77% of students who received School
vouchers were already attending
non-public school institutions yet that
money still disappeared from public
school budgets parents have the right to
select an alternative path for their
children though not at the expense of
other students education and taxpayers
wallets the more the state diverts
public school funding the more local
communities will bear the cost when
already burdened by high property taxes
inflation and housing costs defunding
Public Schools make our state less
competitive as public schools build
strong communities this is why I urge
you to adequately fund public schools
and vote no on
hb15 thank you no questions thank you
very
much uh representative Glenn cordelli
Louise Spencer Hannah
Hannah
yeah thank you very much good afternoon
uh I'm a state representative Glenn
cordelli uh from uh Carol seven uh
Richfield excuse me
Tuftonboro uh wolfboro and oapi and it's
a pleasure to be uh in front of the the
other education uh committee um and I
wasn't going to uh testify but I saw a
quote this morning that uh set me off a
little bit uh the quote is it it always
has been part of their agenda to
continue to remove the state safeguards
on children and to continue to give
parents more and more
control hm parents control um the
Supreme Court in
1925 uh so uh Pierce versus societ of
sisters said that uh the child is not a
mere creature of the
State uh Thomas soul I think put it best
uh the basic question is not what is
best but who says what is best I believe
is in
parents um and that leads to parental
accountability this program has the best
form of accountability it's
parents if the parent is not satisfied
with their child's education they can
move to another education option that
fits their child's
needs that is not always the case with
parents attending a public school
um per perhaps um what we need to do is
unlock the school house doors so that
all parents all children can find the
option that meets their needs and why is
that important because it creates
competition and as we have seen study
after study shows that when there is
school choice available Public Schools
improve um there was an analysis done
not long ago of 29 studies of that
subject 26 found positive results in
public schools one neutral and two found
negative
impact
uh comes quickly doesn't it yes um I'd
be glad to answer any questions thank
you any questions from the committee yes
representa luno thank you very much Mr
chair and thank you very much
representative Elli I was wondering if
you could explain your support for this
program um that uh cannot be audited by
the
state um there is uh an annual audit
required of the children's scholarship
fund um every year um that is on their
website and we can easily give you
copies uh the uh Department of Education
did a compliance audit Mr chair I'm I'm
not talking about the the the business
audit that the children
I said State audit well I said St well
the State Department of Education did a
compliance audit um and the uh
legislative budget assistant is in the
process of uh doing an audit I
understand okay quick followup and what
were the um what were the results of the
um the the state the New Hampshire
Department of Education did a monitoring
exercise compliance audit yeah and I was
wondering if you could you could talk a
little bit about um I I don't have it
with me but I know that there were um a
couple of issues identified in um one
case um there were uh pay stubs used
instead of a tax return because of a
drastic change in income levels for the
family um several instances like that um
and I think there might be someone here
who has more uh information on the
details um of the findings of that
report but uh I think that uh there were
four find excuse me five findings four
were readily corrected and one was uh is
in process because it requires a date
change in the system okay and then and
and in that
monitoring approximately what percentage
of the total number of efas were were
examined during that monitor uh I
believe it was a a random sample of 50
um accounts so approximately 1%
1% is that correct 50 over 5
I guess that's about right okay thank
you uh we will make sure that the
compliance report is available in
everybody's hands here on the committee
it's been out and the oversight
committee's also looked at that uh but
that will be made available represented
fellow do you have a question thank you
um the state has minimum standards for
public schools about the courses that
need to be available in the
qualifications of teachers how do we how
can we know that parents parents who are
homeschooling uh even know what those
standards are and can't come anywhere
near Meeting those
standards are you talking about
homeschool parents who have an education
Freedom account or traditional
homeschool parents the well either the
proposal is that there could be all of
them
so the U the education Freedom accounts
that's what the Bill's about so yeah the
education Freedom account um requires
um uh parents to guarantee that they
will provide uh education for the
children in the basic core subjects
including social
studies that's written into the
law further questions yeah and just a
little followup in terms of look th
those are the courses what about the
standards about what's supposed to be in
the course the curriculum Frameworks
that the public schools use well yeah
let's talk about that um you know I get
a kick out of the accountability
argument because um what are the state
averages in proficiency levels um in my
district I think it's uh something like
54 for English and 44 for math but 96%
of the students
graduate what do those numbers tell you
um just up the line in Conway the uh
proficiency scores are 20% so where is
um you you had a
followup so we're going to keep the wait
we're we're going to keep the follow-ups
two each and you you've had that we have
a whole slug of people to come up here
so I
got yes repan
Brown representative some of the
placards outside mentioned religious
schools were supported by the program
would you mind commenting on that please
thank you um yes I did see that and I
heard someone uh talk about separation
of church and state which appears
nowhere in our constitution it was a
letter written by Thomas Jefferson that
coined that phrase um in terms of money
going to religious
Schools public money does not go to any
school public money goes to
parents parents then with free Choice
direct that money to a religious school
a non-religious school home School
whatever
um that
concept that it becomes private money
goes back many years with constitutional
rulings um one that I know of um that I
have with me uh zelman versus Simmons
Harris 2002 let me quote from Chief
Justice William renquist the Ohio
program is entirely neutral with respect
to religion it provides benefits
directly to a wide spectrum of
individuals it permits such individuals
to exercise genuine Choice among options
public private secular and religious the
program is there is therefore a program
of true private choice that money is
directed for private Choice parental
Choice um and that is reflected in the
most recent Supreme Court rulings uh um
Espinosa versus Mont the Department of
Revenue and most recently uh Carson
versus May uh right here over in Maine
uh had similar rulings with respect to
The Establishment Clause and the fact
that if you provided money to uh any any
school to exclude to exclude religious
schools would be discrimination and
unconstitutional further questions
representa
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you
representative article 83 of New
Hampshire State Constitution states
clearly that quote no money raised by
taxation shall ever be granted or
applied for the use of schools of
institutions of any religious sect or
denomination right could you please help
me understand how that how your
statement that there is no requirement
of separation of church and state
doesn't violate that article of the
Constitution I'm I was thank you for the
question I was referring to the um the
phrase the separation of church and
state is nowhere um that uh Clause the
so-called Blain Amendment named after uh
Senator Blaine um has been uh
adjudicated by the US Supreme Court as I
just laid out um many might refer to
that Blain amendment in our constitution
as a dead
letter um it is a term to indicate that
it is a a statute that can no longer be
enforced uh I if if anyone would like to
test it I know we have another bill
we've had multiple bills on this subject
if anyone would like to test it I
encourage them to file a lawsuit and
let's get it up to the Supreme Court and
have them rule on it one more time what
fun further
questions we already have one represent
Burton thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh a previous
speaker I he was State Rep mentioned
that he went through an e uh program
like this and he was so proud to be
going to one of four colleges that
struck me as interesting that all four
of those colleges are under strict
accreditation with high
standards uh reports that come out
anytime you want to see them not just on
finances but on academic achievement
what they're accomplishing and I know
because of been in higher education
repres Burton do you have a
question why wouldn't the schools that
are getting efas also be subject to
public scrutiny on their effectiveness
of their programs uh all the public ex
me all the private schools that um have
uh attendance from EF a kids have to be
um listed and approved by the Department
and let let me let me just mention also
in regard to that in terms of private
schools um I heard someone mention
Philip's exitor um there was one child
with an EFA going to Philips exitor and
the difference between the EFA and the
tuition is made up by a scholarship from
Philip
exer just quick quick fall where can I
find the reports on the performance of
the schools uh that are getting
efas uh you'd have to contact the school
they don't have an
accreditor uh yes but I'm not sure who
accredits um each of those schools thank
you is there another did you have a
followup go
ahead thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to follow up on my prior question and
response so just to be clear what is
your position on taxpayer dollars
funding religious
schools uh taxpayer dollars go to
parents it then
um the taxpayer
dollars go to parents and in many cases
it's their own tax dollars that are
being used then in their accounts and it
is then a matter of private Choice
whether they send their child to a
religious or non-religious school or
other educational option so you're okay
with taxpayer dollars funding religious
schools I'm okay with taxpayer dollars
going to parents so that they can do
find the best education option for their
children further
questions yes repr yes
Dan yeah I'm at the end of the line
there thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question I
heard a previous uh speaker say that uh
budgets of some uh public schools have
been cut are you aware of any uh Public
School budgets that are lower as a
result of or since the implementation of
this
program um I I don't know if there was
an adjustment in hold harmless or
extraordinary needs grants but that
would be the only way that any um
adjustment of the amount has been uh
done but I don't think that any public
school in New Hampshire or elsewhere in
the nation has received less money then
that they are entitled to under state
law under current existing state law
thank you further questions one last
question rap thank you very much um and
it sort of a followup of on represent
what I thought I heard representative
Maguire ask you which was school budgets
having having been cut so so not the not
the state grants schools having been cut
because we we know from the the um the
Department of Education report that 145
out of
245 uh state grants to Municipal to T
cities and towns for schools were in
fact cut or are going to be in fact cut
for uh for the coming year so um the the
question I heard was was are you aware
of any budgets that were cut as a result
of um the vure program I do know that
when was it three years ago I think um
the Statewide education property tax
which um requires $363 million to be cut
um we cut that to2 $63 million to have
to be collected from uh school districts
and lowered the tax rate um accordingly
but how many local school
districts lowered their budgets based on
that less collection of swept money I
heard maybe there was one or two in
terms of State
budgets so so so so basically what I'm
hearing when you talk about school local
school budgets not being not being cut
as a result of efas that that the efas
have not developed any any tax savings
at the local level is that no no I I
think no there have been tax savings um
to taxpayers um we're talking about
$5,200 in terms of an EFA account on
average whereas the local public school
district uh the current average is
$21,000 in change uh per student so
there is a dramatic difference there we
got to follow the money problem though
the the
the represent luno you're going on with
questions and fine you were having a
sidebar there so no I wasn't having a
sidebar you were having a sidewalk so no
we're done with the questioning here
thank you further
questions thank you very much represent
cordelli uh Lise
Spencer followed by Hannah kesslering
uh Lois
Penza hi um thank you Mr chairman and
thank you committee for taking my
testimony today my name is Louise
Spencer I am from conquered New
Hampshire and I'm also the co-founder of
the Ken Street Coalition which is an all
volunteer Grassroots advocacy
organization one of our top priorities
is uh public schools and making sure
that every child in New Hampshire has
access to the best public school
education that they they can have um
we've heard some compelling stories here
today from people who uh children and
some from children themselves who have
um availed themselves of the EFA Voucher
Program um but there are other stories
we're not hearing uh we're not hearing
from a lot of public public school
students we're not hearing from public
school teachers and there's a reason for
that they're in school and they're not
able to be here and present but they
have compelling stories as well and I
find when I hear the kind of ner
criticisms of public schools it really
breaks my heart because public schools
are so much to so many not only the
children that attend them but the
communities and the families and the
response that they are failing over and
over again I think doesn't take into
account the real challenges our schools
have and the fact that our state has
refused to adequately fund our schools
and adequately fund the public education
of our kids so let's talk about school
vouchers sometime when our state has
already done that then we can have the
conversation
about whether we're going to have school
vouchers yes no child should feel unsafe
whether they're at a public school or
private school sometimes PIV Public
Schools don't meet needs sometimes
private schools don't but without the
adequate funding we're not going to
address the needs of every child and
every child whether they have a parent
who's able to come in here and advocate
for them or homeschool them every child
deserves a fair and adequate and a great
education and that's what most of our
kids get in public schools and we need
to hear more of those stories thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions thank you thank you uh Hann
ring uh Lois
Esposito represent uh representa Kelly
yeah so it is good evening members of
the committee my name is Hannah Kastle
ring I live in Manchester W 12 and I am
in the sixth
grade okay
Jenna this way that
good they want to speak together or not
that per okay I just wanted to tell you
how the EFA program has changed my life
helped me feel more confident because of
it I got to join a swim program try new
subjects and even learn to sew and play
the accordion not every kid gets to do
things like that and it makes me really
happy to play the accordion with my
grandfather it also made me love music
even more I just started voice lessons
and one day I hope to sing the national
anthem for the House of Representatives
I also attend a co-op school where I'm
currently learning about ecosystems and
drama I think every kid should have the
chance to be whatever they want to be
when they grow up my dream is to become
a police officer someday so I hope
you'll think about kids like me when you
vote on this bill please vote Yes for
kids like me thank you for your time
I'll take any questions that you guys
might have thank you Hannah any
questions yes are you saying this was
your choice this was your choice to to
take the grant
um yeah basically I was really excited
about it when I heard about it
so thank you
again have a good afternoon no other
questions you too thank you yeah uh uh
Lois
Esposito or leis is that lisis LE okay
huh Tony for he was when heck of a
brother yeah they that dates me I know
it um thank you honorable chair before
you start going on there we had another
uh sheet come in here from Jenna Carson
I think it said and Owen blood I'd like
to know if they wanted speak together or
separately are they here in the room I
just received this piece of
paper testimony well okay then we need
two cards Al righty uh go ahead Mr EPO
uh honorable chair and committee members
thank you for the opportunity to testify
um my name is Lewis Esposito I'm a
former special education teacher teacher
and currently I'm the executive director
of AEL New Hampshire AEL New Hampshire
is a disability Justice organization
that fights for the civil and human
rights of children and adults with
disabilities school choice programs
often require families to wave essential
legal protections provided under the
idea individuals with disability
Education Act when families use
educational vouchers to enroll in
private schools many private
institutions are not obligated to
provide a services that ensure students
with disabilities are educated in the
least restrictive environment this can
lead to increased segregation of
students with disabil in separate
classrooms or schools inconsistent uh
private schools May lack the staff and
resources to implement their IPs
depriving students of critical support
such as speech therapy assist of
technology and inclusive teaching
practices Universal eligibility could
incentivize the use of efas for private
schools that do not follow inclusive
mandates research shows that families
may feel pressured to accept schools
that only offer self-contained and
specialized classrooms rather than
inclusive settings where students with
disabilities can learn alongside their
peers school choice programs often
exacerbate in inequities for families
from lower income backgrounds
particularly those with students who
have disabilities um for example private
schools participating EFA programs may
not disclose their capacity to support
students with disabilities leaving
families with incomplete information
when making enrollment decisions also
Public Schools typically provide
transportation as part of special
education services but many private
students private schools do not F
further limiting access to inclusive
options for low-income families thank
you further questions thank you sure
yeah represent luno thank thank you very
much so um so so thank you very much um
Mr Esposito for your testimony on this
and um and I believe AEL New Hampshire
was uh was among some uh some groups out
in front of the state house earlier this
week um I was wondering if if you could
talk a little bit about the um the
the the recent reduction or pration in
the special education
uh Aid and what that means Statewide and
compare that to the amount of money
that's that's uh that's being spent on
vouchers right now U represent luno now
we're going to get into the catastrophic
a special education a that is not part
of this bill no no but it's I I think
it's relevant to um to what um to what
what Lewis was talking about if you can
wrap your response around the EFA Bill
we're dealing with hb11
five uh yes um thank you um I think our
rego's concern is inclusive education
practices and when we cut funds um we
are concerned about the different how
that affects teachers within the
classroom and the resources that they're
provided um and you know research will
show that inclusive education um is
beneficial for not just special
education students but also students
that are in the general education
environment okay thank thank you further
questions not see yes representative I
wonder if you can help me um understand
the difference between an EFA budget for
$4,000 and a state mandate to take a a
school with extreme special needs and
send them out to Ohio for $250,000 that
has nothing to do with this bill we are
off the bill I'm not going there with
that question no I'm not going there
with that question um that's a whole div
pration of money and all this no no
thank you thank you very
much yes oh we got one more yes go
ahead thank you Mr chair um can you just
talk a little bit about um the
oversight oh
sorry can you talk a little bit about
the oversight that is provided in public
schools for students with IEPs um versus
what is provided or the lack of what
would be is provided um with students in
efas I and this is the the special
education teacher of me um we we we had
to follow idea and um it was a full team
decision and it we we we try to make it
so that the student and the family are
all part of the team that is the goal
right um and we have to make sure it's
in the least restrictive environment so
uh constant meetings check-ins and
understanding that all students have
different
needs thank
you thank you very much uh represent
Kelly
Penza uh Heather robal
Owen
blood okay we'll go is Heather
here we'll jump with Heather first the
other person's not available at this
moment H I don't see Heather what about
hello my name is Owen blood and I am
currently a senior at kirar Regional
High School I'm here today to advocate
for the support of public schools in New
Hampshire I've been attending Public
School in this state since I was five
and I can say that it has shaped me into
who I am today without a public
education system that provides a
thorough diverse learning experience
kids like me who rely on that system
would not be the same people who we have
grown up to be I have had the incredible
opportunity to learn in public school
and as a product of that system I feel
compelled to do everything in my power
to defend it in our state funding
education is largely determined by
District discretion I am fortunate to
reside in a district that takes
education seriously so this hasn't
greatly impacted me others however are
not so lucky and often face the direct
consequences from a lack of State
funding expanding the state Voucher
Program would directly affect the scho
the funding of schools which is already
notoriously low in districts that want
to maintain a quality of Education
they'd have to P place even more strain
on taxpayers at karge this issue is
already apparent in the community a
citizen petition attempting to
drastically cut the school's budget due
to high taxes was voted on at The
District's deliberative session by
placing the respond possibility of
funding schools on individual districts
you risk the collapse of public schools
due to insufficient funding I urge all
those considering support of hb15 to
think about what this would mean for the
nearly 90% of students in New Hampshire
who are still enrolled in public schools
reducing State funding for public
schools would lower the minimum level of
Education in New Hampshire a student can
receive students in our state deserve
strong Equitable education system and
that starts with adequate funding of f
Public Schools we must ensure that all
students have the resources they need to
succeed thank you very good timing it's
questions not see thank you very much
uh yeah I'm talk like that
yeah well he's been back to the whole
time in that like that I don't let
anybody talk where those things on and
we've also at the door we've been trying
Penza she also has her daughter with
welcome hi my name is Carmela Penza and
I'm 17 years old and I live in Rochester
New Hampshire and I've missed a great
deal of school as you can see due to a
severe medical condition I cannot attend
a public or private school and I need
one-on-one learning getting an EFA would
greatly help my family so they could
hire a tutor so I can complete my high
school
education as it stands now the amount of
work my mom would have to do to be able
to get the district to pay for
everything I need for my education would
be an enormous amount of effort and
frankly a fight my mom several years ago
fought for a boy named Tyler it took
almost 2 years in lawyers and they
finally paid for his Services I was
little but I remember what my family
went through please pass HB 115 to help
me so I'm going to keep it short and
sweet I strongly support the widely
popular EFA program um I do have to say
say that if this doesn't pass and it's
Universal or it gets amended um it has
to be fixed so it's not on gross income
it should be on taxable income because
we would actually apply for this program
if you look at the $440,000 that we've
had to pay out of pocket for carmel's
medical
expenses polling data shows that 72% of
New Hampshire parents support
efas and we must put students over
in the future I would like to see the
EFA program evolve into a more 529
savings plan model I think promoting
transparency accountability fiscal
conservatism and school choice for all
is something that all granted Staters
will support and benefit from thank you
for your time thank you very much other
questions from the
committee not see your hands thank you
very much for
waiting uh
Karen
me the sound gets to you doesn't
this hi thank you Mr chairman and
committee my name is Heather robai as a
parent and active member of the marac
community I'm here to Mo voice my
opposition of
hb15 the existing voucher program is
already available to families 350% of
the poverty level and suffers from a
lack of oversight and
transparency while I support fam's
ability to choose the best Avenue to
educate their children I believe that
public tax should be spent on public
schools public schools hire certified
teachers as well as have regulation and
oversight to ensure all students receive
a free and appropriate public education
our New Hampshire public schools are
already suffering from a lack of funding
resulting in stretch staff and shortage
of personnel to provide critical support
services to our most vulnerable children
at a recent school budget committee a
number of our residents were asking the
district to tighten its belt because
times are tough and Rising property
taxes are threatening to price them out
of their homes expanding the EFA program
would increase the burden on our already
overburden taxpayers while further
undermining our Public Schools it seems
to me that it's fiscally irresponsible
and Reckless to expand this program when
New Hampshire has been failing to comply
with two New Hampshire Supreme Court
rulings regarding its inequitable public
education funding practices thank you
thank you very
much thank you very much there I don't
Manion good afternoon my name is Jenna
Karen and I'm here today to oppose
hp15 the very Foundation of my
opposition to this bill stems from my
success as a prodct of New Hampshire's
Public Schools as a recent graduate from
Sun Middle High School a month ago I
completed my first semester at
Bingington University the best public
university in New York where I'm
thriving academically and actively
participating in campus life and I
consider sunap my New Hampshire Public
School to be the main source of my
accomplishments when I heard about and
researched hb15 it became clear that
this would effectively deface how New
Hampshire values education considering
that it would significantly divert
resources from public education
jeopardizing the Integrity of schools
that enabled students like me to achieve
success hp15 fundamentally changes the
program for one aimed at assisting
families in need to one that prioritizes
funding private education at the expense
of public schools costing over $100
million annually we're moving $ hundred
million would move support for Vital
programs like technical Education
Centers special education School
building aid and safety grants all of
which serve 87% of New Hampshire
students not to to mention over 75% of
voucher recipients were never enrolled
in public schools before receiving funds
illustrating that this program is in
primarily serving public students in
need of alternative options but instead
subsidizing private in homeschool
education therefore the bill raises
questions about accountability and
equity for New Hampshire students it
outlines little oversight of these
public funds no requirement for
financial Audits and no mandatory
assessments to ensure participating
students receive an adequate education
how can we trust that these alternative
Educational Systems are providing the
education New Hampshire students of all
backgrounds deserve with no State
oversight and students with disabilities
W have critical protections under
federal and state disability laws when
they join this program sacrificing their
right to services and indiv
individualized education plans which
enable their success in the classroom
finally long-term studies show that
voucher programs harm student outcomes
participants score significantly lower
in math and reading compared to their
peers in public in public schools why
should we expand a program with evidence
of doing more harm than good rather than
continue and increase and I'll just
finish here increase investment in New
Hampshire's public schools which could
address many of the remarks made by
proponents of the spill overall as a
student who values my education in the
education of my friends family and
future Generations in New Hampshire I
urge the committee to vote against hp15
and to continue supporting our Public
Schools thank you for the opportunity to
speak today thank you very much are
there any
questions our newent president UNH was
being down at Bingington wow yeah yep
all righty thank you uh representative
Smith thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh I'm Tom Manu representing
Hillsboro one pelum it was cool to see
my uh constituent out here earlier darl
Hall uh I'm here in support of hb15 and
I'll keep this brief uh the EFA program
success directly attribute is directly
attributable to the free market force of
providing Superior Products that A
reduced cost due to competition contrast
that with government school programs
where the local taxpayers are burdened
at upwards four times the cost per pupil
with stagnant or even diminishing
returns on investment where local
democracy decides the cost and
individual choice is removed it's
critically important that we expand on
the winning strategy allowing the free
market to do what it does best we don't
means test for government School
admission we shouldn't means test to
allow parents the option to enter the
education Marketplace outside of the
government system I ask that you vote
OTP on hb15 thank you no questions thank
much Ross
Smith Sarah Smith followed by Paul
barley
Caitlyn
here represent fellows would you please
go in the other rooms and see if we have
folks still sitting in those other
yeah there are seats available in here
now so uh I called the name Sarah Smith
and Paul vley and Caitlyn
Scott I I'm Sarah Smith here Sarah
see uh good afternoon um I'm here to
talk about accountability my name is
Sarah Mena Smith I'm from penck New
Hampshire where last year we cut 27
positions due to unfunded cost beyond
what we could afford if they had gone
through our personal tax would have been
at least $3,000 more mine I am a retired
teacher 20 years in public schools and
foreign and private schools specializing
in learning
disabilities I was certified an
elementary Ed General special ed and a
learning disability specialist I was
certified reading recovery teacher Orton
gilingan Lind Mo Bell and Project Read
teacher I spent eight years focused on
struggling first graders and taught them
most of my career one of my duties as a
special ed teacher was evaluating
homeschool students back in the day when
that was required one year I evaluated a
first grader was somewhere around March
I was using the test we normally use it
was immediately clear clear she could
not read so I started her at the
kindergarten level she my cues to read
and probably learned more about reading
during that session than her previous
months with her mother testing at that
level would have put in our remedial
program with onetoone help this was just
one example of why we need to evaluate
all students not just public school
students most of my skills I learned
from for the private school job but they
were easily transferable to my
subsequent public job tuitions for
students at the private school many many
times the school cost were borne by
public schools who failed their students
imagine if we continue down this road
and C cut special ed support education
support and face lawsuits by failed
students comparable to the sununu center
suits today I oppose the use of public
funds for private use and no
accountability and support for more
money for public
schools um I especially appeal to my
representative mahagan that he support
um our public school budget and not
spending public money for private
schools thank you very much any
questions questions not see any thank
you very much thank you uh I Paul barley
is Paul
around
all right hi my name is Caitlyn Bernier
and I'm a resident of marac New
Hampshire and I'm here in opposition of
the HB 115 I have two children in the
public education and one of them is in
special education as our public school
districts are currently going through
budget season with even less State
funding and facing detrimental Cuts this
bill will continue to take away money
from public education expanding School
voucher eligibility for all students
regardless of family income could cost
the state approximately 120 120 $ 102
million in the 2526 school year alone
according to a new study by reaching
higher ed uh higher New Hampshire this
would deplete our education trust fund
which is projected to have 125 million
in the fiscal year 2025 that is
84% of our current fund spent just on
the
efas edel but recently said he would be
working with lawmakers to pass a bill to
support District's special education
expenses but passing HP 115 would leave
no money for those students and that
would increase the taxpayers burden this
is not fair to the children receiving
special education and your state
obligation to public education properly
funding special education and public
education should be the first priority
I'm not opposed to the current EFA
program that has income limits I am
opposed to this change those of us that
are using public education should not
have to suffer more funding cuts and
increases in our taxes for those that
have the privilege to use home school
and afford private school that is all I
have thank you thank you very much any
questions are there any questions not
seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you uh saror
Scott not
here
yeah all right thank you excuse me
you're gonna have to take the yellow
label off please we we don't have any of
those buttons or anything like that
thank you all right uh well thank you Mr
chair Vice chair and members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
here today my name is Sarah Scott and
I'm the deputy state director for
Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire uh I'm here today to testify
in support of HB 115 which seeks to
expand education Freedom accounts to
every student in New Hampshire we
believe that every child is unique and
with that comes different learning needs
families know their children's needs
better than anyone else and empowering
them with the tools to choose the right
education path can make a world of
difference in their lives expanding efas
to every student is not just about
providing options but it's about
removing barriers to opportunity and
giving them the room to
thrive as a New Hampshire native I have
a deep appreciation for the unique
character of our state and the strong
sense of community that defines it this
is where I grew up and it's where I've
chosen to build my life in my career
many of my friends from childhood left
the state for college and didn't come
back because of the High Cost of Living
of the friends who have stayed many of
them are now growing their families and
sending their children off to school
this has led to numerous conversations
about the education options in the state
and one thing has become clear from
these conversations giving parents the
choice to find an education option that
works for their family is a crucial
factor in their decisions about whether
or stay in New Hampshire those friends
who stayed here after college are
struggling to balance the High Cost of
Living New Hampshire while also finding
an educational environment that allows
their child to succeed these families
are looking for options and want the
best for their children even if that
means moving out of state one of my
friends is currently expecting her
second child and with a growing family
the ability to choose an education for
her family and also afford to stay in
the state is a big concern she's having
to make tough decisions for her family
about how they will afford child care
for the youngest purchase a home and
find an education that works for their
oldest her story is not unique and
you've heard many of the kids here today
that have expressed these same concerns
I will uh wrap up my testimony here and
send you all the remainder of it but
thank you for your time today thank you
very much are there any questions not
seeing any
uh Leah wki and then Susan Spence and
here so we're looking for Susan Spence
Leo Wii here I said she's here but Miss
Mali is not
okay so can I go ahead Who Who Are You
Now Spence Susan oh yes go ahead Susan
okay my name is Susan Spence and I am a
10 and a half year resident pres of uh
do New Hampshire prior to that I was the
education librarian at a Jesuit school
in Upstate New York and need get real
closer like that to the mic many years
prior to that I was the uh librarian at
an inner city school system where 49% of
the students live below the poverty line
most of my comments are in regard to
special ed programs and how this uh
proposed bill will impact them um in
November uh of last year the education
commission commissioner announced a
severe cut in state aid to special
education the aid is being cut from um
98.3% of the cost in
2023 to TW to
67.5% in this year this creates a
particularly hard hardship for schools
in rural areas because many of them do
not possess the services required to
meet uh Federal mandates for special
education and so they have to contract
for these with ad Jason school districts
or have private providers and then they
have to transport the students to those
locations um currently schools are
responsible for
$70,000 per student costs and the state
contributes to anything in excess of
this commissioner Ed Adel blut has not
requested an increase in the state
special education budget since 2021 even
though the costs have clearly
increased the
33.9% million that was allotted last
year had already received $50 million of
request from school districts by October
1st of last year less than a month into
the school
year um commissioner Adel claims to have
no solution to the uh budget dilemma but
he believes that but vouchers may be the
solution a very simple search on my part
revealed the FCI justness of this
reasoning number one uh a large p a
number of research studies conducted
between 2008 and
2018 find no improvement in student
achieve a m when vouchers are used some
of the agencies conducting these studies
were the economic policy Institute the
National Bureau of economic research and
the institute for uh educational
Sciences secondly the voucher system has
already exceeded its uh initial estimate
and cost so I will not get to the third
point which is that most private schools
do not provide any uh special ed
services they're not not mandated to do
so why would New Hampshire validate such
an expensive Venture when it has no
proven positive outcome thank
you uh a
question I don't know do you want to
questions quick question thank you very
much yeah you can come back to the um no
thank thank thank you very much um Miss
fence um would the um would the $27
million that was was spent on that's
being spent on the voucher program this
year cover the shortfall in um special
education Aid that you were referring to
I I can't answer that I don't know um
apparently the special voucher program
is administered by a private agency and
according to the education commissioner
can't be audited because of this so okay
how much transparency of data there is
thank you thank
yeah thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee I appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you today about
Universal education Freedom accounts my
name is Adam hsto and I'm a resident of
Hudson my wife and I have two young
children my almost 5-year-old daughter
starts kindergarten this fall and my
three-year-old son will start in Fall of
2027 which is in two years we would like
to send our children to a local private
school in Hudson but unfortunately we
don't qualify for an EA this is because
our income is slightly above the current
eligibility requirements for
efas as we consider the future of educ
ation in our state I urge you to support
Universal education Freedom accounts a
program that empowers parents to make
the best education choices for their
children by providing a flexible
education funding system efas give
parents the freedom to choose the best
education for their child whether that's
a traditional public school private
school or home school this approach will
improve academic outcomes increase
efficiency and promote accountability in
the education system efas promote
efficiency by allowing parents to direct
education funding to the schools and
programs that best meet their child's
needs by giving parents more control
over education funding efas increase
accountability and transparency in the
education system education shouldn't be
dependent on zip code or income it
should be based upon what parents beli
is in the best interest of their child I
believe that Universal education Freedom
accounts are a critical step toward
creating a more Equitable and Effective
Education System in New Hampshire I urge
you to support this legislation and give
all parents the freedom to ch choose the
best education for their children thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions not seeing any thank you is
here all right sorry I'm a little
disheveled here I came from uh from work
so uh I'm representative Ross bar I
represent the towns of wear and gtown I
was watching the um committee remote so
I don't need to reiterate a lot of the
points uh but I would like to raise some
things um especially to my colleagues on
the other side of the aisle you do not
income test a public school this is
public
education so I don't know why we would
start applying a income test now no one
says anything when a family making a
million dollars goes to public school no
one says oh my God you're hurting the
taxpayer um they view it as a duty
education should be about funding
students not systems
um I am the byproduct of both public and
private school I was pulled out of
public school um because it did not meet
my needs as a child my parents then put
me into private school and then my dad
lost his job he was the only income
earner in my family and um you know this
is right around Middle School not a
great time for teenagers and I remember
very very very tough conversations and
let's call it arguments and yelling
about whether they were going to pay the
mortgage or pay for my schooling so you
guys have an opportunity here to do real
good the money belongs to the student uh
people raise objections about I don't
want my tax dollars going to a private
school I don't care where you send my
education tax dollars I want them to
follow the student if that goes to a
private school so be it I had a friend
of mine on the other side of the aisle
said would you be okay if this money
went to a school and isamic school like
trying to poke some religious bigotry
out of me they were kind of stunned when
I said I'd have no problem with that if
that's what the parent wants to do
that's the parents business parents
should raise their children as they see
fit even if I disagree with that they
should raise their children as I as they
see fit and the money that is taken from
taxpayers is for the student so I won't
uh berate that anymore but I'm happy to
be here to testify in favor of this and
happy to answer any questions got three
more seconds nailed
[Laughter]
it are there any questions yes represent
luno then representative fellows thank
you very much Mr chair thank you very
much representative Barry so so you
talked about um uh the equivalency of um
of what should be vouchers and um having
having no um no eligibility requirement
the same way um the same way as we have
currently for for public schools but um
would I guess would you support an
amendment to um uh to this bill that
would put some accountability some
testing some data sharing and an annual
state audit reporting requirement into
um into the voucher program yeah well
let's talk about accountability real
fast no no let's answer the question no
no I'm allowed to answer as I see fit
let's answer I'm allowed to answer as I
see fit so you guys bring up
accountability all the time as you know
I used to represent the south side of
Manchester Mr chair the question was
represent luno you asked about
accountability he is responding to you
on accountability he'll get to where you
want to be okay thank you thank you so I
would ask ask this question so in
Manchester you have Ela uh and math
proficiencies in the teens in the teens
who's accountable for that and I
understand that this is the perjorative
that is constantly thrown calling it a
voucher program trying to drive the
program into the ground saying it's
unaccountable the money belongs to the
child so you can sit there and push
forward in the amendment all you want
and say all you want if you're going to
make an accountability argument
representative my Counterpoint would be
I would start with the failing school
systems first which cost five times as
much as this program
does are there further questions well he
he didn't get to the answer of my
question you have a followup so so so
would you would you support an annual
audit uh performance an annual state
performance audit on the um the voucher
program I I would start with if you want
to talk about accountability which is
your point I would start with holding
the public schools accountable first the
money belongs to the students I'm
talking about an audit the the public
schools are a the money is very well the
money is very well accounted for now
thank you very much are there any are
there any other
questions thank oh yes represent fellows
yeah thank you uh you're the second
person I've heard refer to you know the
money belongs to the child and you don't
want to fund
systems so what is this I don't quite
understand not funding systems does that
mean that that you don't think the
federal government should pay for the
military to to protect our country that
sounds like a system
you know do you think that the town
shouldn't um fund police or or Public
Works should everybody get the money to
maintain the roads that they live on how
does that work I don't understand this
concept yeah Happ to clarify for you um
there are members of this legislature
who prioritize the system over the
student so doesn't mean you don't
properly fund school systems but the
student should be the priority and I
think that's a key difference that's one
of the things I love this bill is makes
the student and the parent the priority
over the system and I will always be I
will always have the backs of students
and parents before the system when it
comes to education the order of
operations is very simple students
parents system not the other way around
students parents
system thank you very much further
questions pardon me oh yes you're
blending right in with all the other
traffic that
I know I feel like I'm a part of the
crowd here um thank you Mr chair you're
welcome and oh jeez thank you Mr chair
um there's this bill is about
eligibility and Universal eligibility um
in in my free time one of the things
that I do is I'm a volunteer um who does
SNAP Outreach and so I talk to people
about we're not really hearing you on
the other side really get close to that
mik so I do snap Outreach and education
across the state and the first question
that I get when I talk to people is what
are the income
guidelines and we've heard a lot of
stories today about people who are just
over the guidelines for um for the
vouchers and that happens all the time
for SNAP so I guess my question to you
is would you be in favor of eliminating
income eligibility for programs like
Snap and tanif and and fuel
assistance um well I can't speak to
those programs specifically but I think
more to Broad your question about uh I
believe they're called um benefit Cliffs
right income Cliffs and I deal with this
a lot actually in the childcare space
where we have a state scholarship which
is kept up at 350% it's actually the
same income level right now as an EFA um
and I deal with that all the time with
parents uh who fall off they're at the
they're at the 360 or uh worse actually
probably the worst thing is they're a
small business owner and you look at
gross income and not net income uh and
you disqualify a lot of a lot of small
business owners who actually would make
it if you look at their net income but
anyways that's neither here nor there um
this is about education and you know the
state constitution says we should
cherish education and I view that as a
constitutional Duty so uh I don't see
anything in there about snap or the
state constitution or those other
programs um so I guess my answer would
be
no thank you further questions
not see thank you very
much uh Janet Ward followed by
heny so we have all these other people
waiting waiting waiting waiting waiting
my name is Janet Ward I am the vice
president of the League of Women Voters
of New Hampshire a nonpartisan
organization I thank thank you for this
opportunity in 2017 the newly appointed
Commissioner of Education Frank
edelblute was invited to address the
annual meeting of the league during the
question and answer period following his
talk I asked the commissioner what do
you see is the role of public schools in
our
democracy at the close of our
conversation in December 2019 the
commissioner told me that he believed
that public dollars should pay for
private education and that I did not
believe this he was correct I believe
what Thomas Jefferson and other founding
fathers believed that participation in a
democracy a form of government which
respects the Divergent views of its
citizens requires an educated populace
this is why the public schools were
established all of us present here today
recognize that New Hampshire school
Voucher Program takes tax dollars from
taxpayers like me and requires that I
give these dollars to parents or
Guardians to pay for the private
religious or homeschooling of their
children applicants from for New
Hampshire vouchers apply to a private
organization which screens applicants
and presumably ensur that all monies are
properly spent the New Hampshire
legislative budget assistance assistant
is required by Statute to do a
performance audit of New Hampshire
school voucher program but the LBA is
unable to do this because it has not
been given access to this information
once School vouchers consisting of New
Hampshire taxpayer dollars are awarded
taxpayers do not have any appreciable
oversight on how their tax dollars are
spent unlike taxes provided to our local
public schools the money taken from us
as voucher dollars disappears from
taxpayer oversight this constitutes
taxation without representation one of
the key reasons why the original 13
colonies revolted against Great Britain
I believe a citizen's revolt against
School vouchers should and eventually
will happen thank you thank you very
much are there
questions thank you very much you're
welcome uh representa n then Doris hensy
Hill which
one okay
ago yeah good afternoon thank you Mr
chair and members of the education
funding committee my name is Karen Leo
Hill I am honored to serve as the
executive counselor for district 2 I am
also a 20-year city counselor and the
former mayor in Lebanon as someone who
homeschooled for high school I'm not
here to talk talk about the merits of
the voucher program I know that um I
know that different students have
different needs and that there are many
different ways of making sure that our
kids have access to the education that
they need I'm here today to TA to
Advocate specifically for
taxpayers as we heard in the governor's
inaugural address last week we have to
tighten our belts clearly we are looking
at budget cuts at the state state level
and I know very well from firsthand
experience as a city counselor that when
Cuts happen at the state level local
property taxes go up so on behalf of the
81 cities and towns of District 2 I'm
here to encourage you to um to itl this
bill um because we simply local property
taxpayers simply cannot afford it thank
you thank you very much are there
questions from the committee
not see thank you have a good drive home
to
here
here oh yeah okay yeah okay we'll get
after
this chairman lad members of the
committee I'm darus heny mother of six
homeschool children and a former
nashille School Board member I'm here in
opposition parents are frustrated with
schools rightly so the legislature has
destroyed them with costly and
controversial regulation resulting in
higher property taxes and no voice in
public school that okay I will the
legislature accepted Federal bribes on
an ongoing basis to implement
standard-based learning as if children
were Commodities to standardized well
it's not working instead of creating a
new entitlement the legislature should
take responsib ability for the current
situation regul the reg overregulation
of public schools and restore local
control but that's too difficult or it's
all the federal government's fault so we
have to a new plan to provide State
funding for every child rich or poor who
attends private schooling to help them
get the best education best education
really that I mean that's what they said
about the public schools when they put
in all this regulation funding private
school is not a constitutional Duty
under article 83 that's for public
schools we are being being told that
every school child learns differently
really Public Schools were not allowed
to treat children as individuals we are
burdened with uniform standards uniform
assessments uniform compty based
education and uniform social emotional
learning which is behavior modification
it's one-sized fits-all centralized
control eliminating any real
accountability no one's ever to blame
nothing ever changes the schools fail
they just get more funding the original
article six gave us an exclusive right
over education I put that in I'll skip
over it but it's in there for your
review every public school is a
corporate body not a body comma
corporate as they mutilated it in ' 68
the state created teacher licensing for
public schools now it funds improves
private schools without licensed
teachers Tate created academic standards
and mandates for public schools but
funds private schools without those it
creates laws on employee labor standards
for public schools and now funds
improved private schools without such
unions
the state has required public has
regulated public schools to death which
is why public schools are failing and
spending out of control the state
legislature wants to cut costs
deregulate the schools one other thing I
just want to say that school choice is
not a Grassroots movement like
homeschooling it's an agenda pushed by
Nationwide think tanks legislative
conferences and advocated by UNESCO
which favors State control of Education
to produce Global Citizens with values
attitudes and beliefs different from
those of their fames you gone beyond
your time I have it's an important issue
and I thank you and I haven't seen you
in such a long time it's nice to see you
again I'm sorry Barbara Shaw isn't here
I miss her she was wonderful she was a
wonderful wonderful
Lukie thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee I will be very
brief because I believe this has been
pounded to death I would like to say 71
years ago I was in a room they called it
a first grade classroom however uh there
was something that was missing the
missing part of it was Miss Tui Miss Tui
was sick all year uh Miss Tui did manage
to get through to her retirement 30 kids
got the shaft and I'm hearing the
stories from the kids earlier today and
the parents earlier today and the more
things change the more things remain the
same if the schools are failing if
they're failing one student then that
student should be able to get an
adequate and appropriate education
however is necessary um and if the
public schools can't do it then we need
an Escape Route thank you thank you very
there we
go and the next person would be
representative uh wood or Clayton
wood I'm in support of the bill the
existing EFA laws and anything that
makes them more
accessible and I'd like to use the rest
of my time to talk about how to make it
even
better I think there's a the problem
with the existing EFA law is that it's
not full replacement cost so parents
have come
up
what the problem is that it's not full
replacement cost uh to to fund the
private school um and and then parents
have to come up with money on their own
no matter what their income look the
secondary problem is that the state
revenue needs to be raised at the at the
fund at the state level and the solution
the punchline headline is town
efas and if I use an example from my
town of marac uh the the town school
budget is 93 mil 3600 students over
25,000 per student I look quickly on the
EFA the the State website and found
three neighboring schools Terry field
about 26k and Manchester that's a break
even Trinity High School Manchester 15K
Bedford Academy a k35 under 14k that
includes lunch
the total school budget in marac is
2third of the Town budget so making a
significant reduction in the school
budget would significantly reduce
property
taxes so the details to
consider towns decrease payments to
school districts maybe mandate that as
instantaneous or catch it in next year's
budget towns could decide on the amount
it could be a direct reimbursement to
the school or a flat fee homeschooling
could certainly be included in this the
state infrastructure for efas Remains
the single payment from the town could
go to that State office and they could
administer all of
the payments to the individual places so
the punchline are your property taxes
too high do you support school choice
solve both problem at once support town
efas thank you very much questions from
the committee not seeing any uh Charles
is is is a representative I asked wood
here no uh Charles Smith and then
Richard
AEM Kitty
MTI if I'm pronouncing names just please
let me know that I'm messing it up
it's getting late in the game here good
afternoon my name is Kitty motti I'm
from Dairy New Hampshire and I am here
in support of this bill um as part of
New Hampshire's Constitution to provide
an adequate education for students that
goes into meeting the needs of
them through educational content Andor
other
resources for those students who have
been homeschooling this entire time I
myself as a taxpayer for 10 years before
we were able to take advantage of the
EFA program I now very much appreciate
that the tax dollars I paid for 10 years
are now coming back to me so that I can
provide an adequate education for my
children one I've heard a whole lot of
testimony today going back and forth on
both sides one thing that has not been
addressed is that the people against
this particular bill will be funded no
matter what the people for it will not
the people who are hoping to become
funded by an expansion of the EFA
program will not have another choice for
their adequate funding they are counting
on you all to do what you did for me
last year which was expand it to
350% there's a whole lot of students
that I teach that would really
appreciate being able to become EFA
students whether they use it for private
that's all thank you very
much questions thank you uh you and
Osborne and David Trumble and Sandra May
in that
order uh I apologize I just need to pull
up my
testimony um thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee good
afternoon my name is aan Osborne and I'm
both a student instructor at a
homeschool Learning Center and a
homeschooler who is bened from school
school choice I am here today to ask you
to please support HB 115 throughout my
high school career I've explored almost
every educational pathway from
homeschool co-ops to commun Community
College classes to even internships I
have tried it all I am truly fortunate
when it comes to my choices for
educational
opportunities unfortunately not everyone
else is as fortunate as I am when it
comes to educational options we made
great strides in financially assisting
lower class families and the request for
education Choice via the introduction of
Education Freedom accounts however a
certain group remains neglected the
middle class the current income
threshold for efas does not account for
the financial situations of individual
families and despite falling above the
350% income threshold there are still a
good number of families who struggle to
afford school choice several of these
families send their students to the hes
School Co-op I work at I've heard
firsthand how hard it can be to afford
their chosen education that doesn't mean
that these families don't deserve the
same choices that the of us have
universalizing efas would equalize the
playing field for these families I'm
aware that there are several me members
of The Homeschool Community who oppose
both this bill and efas in general most
of these individuals are elitists who SE
selfishly wish to gatekeep school choice
so that it is only an option for wealthy
families these individuals have no
business thinking that their school
choice experiences Trump anyone else's
please give middle class students the
opportunity for educational choice and
vote Yes on HP 115 thank you thank you
very much questions yes represent mam
thank you for coming thank you for your
courage and your compassion I have one
question you made these choices for your
own education or you participated
strongly in them right are you asking if
I'm an I'm asking because you you're
obviously a product of your choices that
you made this was your education and you
made the choice you you liked what you
got I did um my parents did also have
some say over it of course thank you
that's all thank you very much further
questions thank you for coming today
thank you Mr chairman you're welcome
May you've been a frequent flyer here in
past years how's wear doing I'm pretty
good Mr chairman thank you I'm David
Trumble from the town awar and I oppose
this bill for two reasons first is the
impact it would have on our
constitutional duty to fund Public
School schools the Constitution requires
that the state not the towns fund the
public schools and the Claremont
decision was very clear there's no
requirement to fund the private schools
the US Supreme Court has upheld that
same logic in the case that was I
believe not quite accurately quoted
earlier it was the Carson versus Mon
case chief judge Robert said as we held
in espanosa a state need not subsidize
public education you have to fund the
public schools and you have to do it
fully you do not have to spend a dime on
private schools once you fund the public
schools and do your job then go ahead
and do a voucher program second issue is
the issue of choice this is universal
vouchers but it's not Universal Choice
let's look at some of the people who
would be left out first is special
education students over 20% of public
school students receive special ed only
6% in the voucher program and they have
to sign away their rights under the
idea look at elll students there's 5,000
in New Hampshire that's 3% of our
students under the last report there is
zero in the voucher program look at
children living in poverty that's 7% of
the children in the state the average
cost of a private school in New
Hampshire is $221,600 they can't afford
to pay that there may be some lowcost
private schools some places with
scholarships but largely people who are
poor cannot participate lgbtq students
make up 22% of high school students not
all but there are some private schools
who ban lgbtq students from attending
lgbtq parents 5% of our adult population
identify as lgbtq but if you have two
moms or two dads many of the voucher
schools won't let you attend there's
nothing Universal about Universal
vouchers the only Universal option you
have is the public schools because they
accept every single child and they give
every one of them a good education and
that's why we have a constitutional Duty
to fund them and there is no
constitutional duty to fund the private
schools thank you thank you very
much
sir thank you very much for taking my
question if you believe that the state
should be funding the schools and that
it should not be something that the
local taxpayers are paying do you also
believe then that the state should be
responsible for the budget in which
they're funding
you asking if the state should fund
public school education I believe I just
heard you say that it's our
constitutional Duty that the state
should be funding Public Schools is that
correct what I heard yes representative
so if the state should be funding them
do you also agree that the state should
be responsible for all of the expenses
and therefore be responsible for putting
together the budget for the public
schools as well those are two different
things the state has the duty to fund
under the um Claremont decision it said
that the state must guarantee the
funding but the actual running of the
schools is not required under the
Clarmont decision that's left to the
local school
boards thank you yes represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair and and
thank you very much Mr Trumble so when
it when it comes to the state's funding
of public schools are you aware that um
that based on the department of Ed the
New Hampshire Department of Ed data that
this committee received earlier this
week that um that wear is ejected to
receive
$664,000 less next year from the state
than it receives today thank you
representative luno last night we had
our local Schoolboard meeting in advance
of our deliberative session and that
came out that we are losing 600,000 but
under the uh Readjustment of the
adequacy aid we're getting some of that
back so we're really losing 460,000 net
that's 35 cents per
thousand on every home in our state so
it's like 100 and our town like
$160 that's the first of five
installments that we're going to lose
under the hold harmless plan so we had
the stabilization Grant to help towns
like mine that don't have an adequate
property tax base this coming two-year
cycle we lose 20% of the stabilization
Grant so my town is going to lose
460,000 the two years after that we'll
lose another 460 then another 460
another 460 another 460 the average
taxpayer in my Town's going to end up
paying like ,000
more just because we cut the
stabilization fund so pull that back to
the voucher program where do we fund
public schools from in the state the
education trust fund where are we
funding the voucher program from the
education trust fund if you expand this
program and reaching higher says it's
going to cost $100 million that's going
to mean a 100 million less than the
education trust fund that's going to
suck that fund dry and there won't be
enough money for the public schools so
there is a direct relationship I'm not
opposed to every kid getting what they
want I think it's that that's how we
should should make it work but our first
obligation is to fund the public schools
and last thing is when they set up the
education trust fund 25 years ago it was
in response to the kount decision there
were Democrats and Republicans together
who set that fund up so that we funded
the public schools not to fund private
schools but that's where we now take the
money for the voucher program out so
there's a direct connection between the
public school funding and the voucher
welcome do you have will you take
further questions course mire you have
no
question yeah or name oh no question I
apologize okay thanks okay uh Sandra May
is here right
here well that was a tough act to follow
uh good afternoon members of the House
committee uh my name is Sandra May and
I'm from Haner to talk to you today I'm
taking a break from mudding drywall in
the new apartment that my husband and I
have built while I'm proud to do
something small to fight the housing
crisis in the state my main reason for
building an Adu is that without a unit
we can rent out I don't see how we can
keep paying our property tax when we
retire that said I'm hopeful this
apartment will help one more family
either stay in New Hampshire or entice
some badly needed workers here our
educated Workforce has been a big New
Hampshire strength hearing that we're
facing budget cuts this year I don't
understand why why we're blowing up the
budget by opening up these vouchers to
everyone regardless of need what is this
diversion of public funds going to do to
our Public Schools especially when some
districts have lacked Equitable funding
for decades what message are we sending
to the young people we want to stay here
or come here a $4,000 voucher is not
going to go very far at St Paul's but
thousands of dollars diverting funds
from schools is ultimately going to make
property taxes increasing even more
while home ownership grows further Out
Of Reach if people want their child to
have good education they'll either have
to stretch to find the rest of the money
for private school or someone in the
household is going to have to step back
on their career to home school this
doesn't sound like a great way to entice
Working Families to live here at all I
understand that several of the previous
speakers have made that exact difficult
Choice excellent Public Schools should
still be a viable option and I'd like to
reiterate what Louise Spencer said
earlier you're not hearing from these
Working Families they are they're at
work right now I don't mind paying taxes
not to fund policing or public parks or
the education of more electricians for
New Hampshire having just built a
housing using unit of trust me we need
more trades people in this space I in
closing is this really the New Hampshire
Advantage we're just going to keep
ignoring the courts and give up on
Equitable funding for strong Public
Schools I thank the committee for their
time thank you very
Grio thank you chairman lad and the
members of the education funding
committee for the record my name is
Matthew greo I'm a college student
currently at St an college and I'm from
lville New Hampshire and I've been
through the public education system the
education Freedom accounts represent a
critical step towards true educational
freedom and by limiting the household
income requirement this bill helps get
New Hampshire one step closer to a
stronger Freer education system by
giving parents the ability to direct
their own education funds that they pay
through taxes towards the the learn
environment that best suits their
child's unique needs we are finally
freeing the public education system from
the the Monopoly it holds over most
families that has led to Statewide
educational
decline historically the ability for
parents to choose the best education for
their children has been largely confined
to the independently wealthy who could
with ease afford private schools or
alternative options this bill ends the E
economic barrier returns the power of
school choice to All Families regardless
of their socioeconomic
status furthermore efas serve as a
powerful Catalyst for improvement within
our public education system by expanding
the access accessibility of the
education Freedom accounts to all New
Hampshire families giving them the
option to choose alternative education
paths Public Schools face a healthy
competition they are incentivized to
Prior prioritize quality and efficiency
in meeting the needs of all their
students this competition Fosters a far
more responsive educational landscape
ultimately benefiting all children
throughout New Hampshire thank you thank
you very much are there any questions
see thank you
again
uh honorable Linda Tanner is she still
over here in the hallway or is Linda out
she just
left okay represent James tibo is he out
there in the
hallway oh in back okay thank
you yeah got him I was lucky enough to
get a seat next one's uh Bonnie Bruno
after this hello my name is James TBO I
am the representative for Franklin in
Northfield mayor M County District 25 uh
and I'm also a product of a public
school and a student at St Anam College
I'm here to advocate in favor of HB 1115
because education freedom is a right
that um of every student and should be
access as accessible as possible to
every student I grew up with two special
needs sisters one older one younger and
public school failed them they were told
by public school that they were
incapable of learning and that be they'd
be unable to graduate from high school
so we moved on to a charter school and
the charter school really helped my
older sister who ended up graduating
High School when the public school said
she
wouldn't unfortunately the charter
school was not helping my younger sister
who is now in homeschooling and working
with an independent special needs um
teacher to be able to um best suit her
needs and now she's succeeding where the
Char even the charter school thought she
would fail um they thought she wouldn't
be able to do algebra well right now
she's in pre-algebra but she's working
her way up to algebra in ways that the
charter school wasn't able to get her to
and the only reason we could afford that
um private instructor was because of
efas um education Freedom allows more
students to be engaged with the subjects
that they care about in more Hands-On or
intimate settings as needed um just like
my sister who has been able to learn
better from them um and they're not
constrained to a one-sized fits-all
public school classroom efas are also
more cost- effective to the taxpayer
while offering more opportunities for
these students um and especially with
struggling public schools in Lower Class
areas including the SA in my district um
which have declining enrollment rates um
having more resources available to all
parents is critical so for these reasons
and to fund students not systems I
encourage the committee to find hb15 on
to pass thank you and I will not yield
to questions thank you very
and in the hallway we must have a child
out there uh a mom with kids yes you'll
be
next me me me me me is that better okay
um my name is Bonnie Brun I'm a Hollis
resident I do appreciate being able to
speak today in a public forum most of
this may have been said but the fact
that my pocking ticket probably has
pocking ticket I'm going to go ahead and
take the
time um so I stand in opposition of the
education Freedom accounts and the
expansion of the same as a taxpayer I do
not want to subsidize private private
religious or homeschooling options I
want to fund the public school and the
Commonwealth as somebody already said I
don't mind paying taxes I believe in the
Commonwealth um I'd like to have the
money that is um being used about 10% to
facilitate the program at the New
Hampshire children's scholarship fund to
actually be in the school system and
funding the actual school system um
private and religious and homeschooling
institutions are not accountable to the
public have no public oversight or input
and do not have to be transparent in
their policies and procedures to the
public for example private and religious
and even homeschooling
programs um can use uh
discriminating wrong dword can use
Discerning in their enrollment process
making decisions and exclude students
was much more eloquently described just
a few minutes ago um exclude students
and it's not inclusive whereas public
schools are inclusive um I have so many
notes on here from sitting there taking
notes that it's like good luck to me
trying to follow this but you know my
nephew was in um two different religious
private schools and was severely bullied
and so had to be pulled out of them so
you know Bullying happens not a good
thing um my friend is a single parent
who had a hot economic challenges in the
um lfi Public Schools educated her son
so he became uh went on to become a
brown graduate and that was thanks to
the New Hampshire Public Schools well um
while some may say that they too pay
taxes and they want their tax dollars to
fund their school choice I say I their
choice I say I hear you except I would
like to allocate my tax dollars as well
but we don't have that system which we
can earm Mar and allocate our tax
dollars because if we did I would not
elect to fund the EFA accounts um I said
one quote I want to read read which is
you know this seems to be a nationwide
and certainly happening in New Hampshire
that from the pruer article I read that
starting with targeted programs that
place needy kids in parochial schools
then fight to expand the benefits to
far- richer families is an effort by a
network of politicians Church officials
and activists all United by a conviction
that there is separation of church and
state is a legitimate I believe that the
separation of church and state is
legitimate as pointed out earlier by
representative Damon and and
um thank you I would rather support the
Commonwealth um by my taxes thank
you thank you very
much
um the young lady with a youngster
outside I don't have your name
here diver
okay okay Kelly diver thank you very
much I'm sorry they were starting to
lose their their
coal um so my name is Kelly diver and oh
there we go um my name is Kelly diver
and I live in Danville New Hampshire um
there is an issue with our public
schools in our country and I find it
really amazing that people from school
boards and budget committees are coming
in here and saying that efas are the
problem they talk about being F fiscally
responsible I think that they need to
look in the mirror and realize that
there is a supply and demand issue
enrollment is down yet taxes go up and
parents want a choice we are EFA
students and I can tell you that our
public school district has been
mismanaging funds for over the last 5
years the budget went up 15% and they
had a $16 million surplus and put in
tennis lights and an irrigation pond
with a boat for
decoration why are we not holding these
budget committees and school boards
responsible we are spending all this
money and the kids are not passing their
tests if they can't do basic budgeting
and math how can I trust them to educate
my child I spend a small percentage of
what is spent on public school students
and I am able to educate my son we are
grateful for our EFA support and urge
you to support hp15 thank you thank you
very much any questions any questions
yes represent fellows yes just can you
explain to me how you're educating
yourself yeah many um we do private
curriculum and Co Co-op opportunities um
we have them enrolled in Co-op classes
we also do on nature school one day a
week um so we do different we kind of
blend a lot of different
opportunities yeah thank you yeah thank
you thank you ready next next uh Mike
and Judah
thank you chair and committee Mike King
and Judah King from Dearing New
Hampshire um so I just want to get this
straight when a business offers a
failing product they go under but when a
public school offers a failing product
we get upset that they're losing a
fraction of their
budget uh the cat is out of the bag
especially since covid I'd like to say
in 2020 we saw 2020 and a lot of parents
have decided not to go back to the
school so we can have disagreements over
empirical data but the perception of the
public is that the schools are feeling
academically morally um all the Press
about diversity Equity inclusion and the
rising and out of control administrative
costs
um the future of Education I think we're
seeing is micro schools and this new
form of Education I saw an article
recently that said by
2030 30% of America's students will be
homeschooling that's only in 5
years um so and then the last thing I
wanted to just say was that New
Hampshire will really continue to set
itself apart from uh all the other New
England states uh as you continue to
offer education Freedom you'll attract
uh strong families from all over New
England and isn't that what um New
Hampshire wants you know strong families
that will add to the economy
uh and in all all kinds of great ways I
want to introduce you to Judah King here
he wants to uh talk about he's how he's
benefited from the education Freedom
account you got to talk
right hi my name is Judah King and I am
here to support the school choice I live
help me advance my knowledge in Reading
Writing and
math learn the I have learned the drums
and now I'm able to take drum lessons
because of it my sister has a passion
for horses and she's able to take horse
lessons my brother is loves music and he
is able to purchase softwares and uh
that's helped him with music and I've
learned all about how to start a
business and be an entrepreneur so that
one thank you very much questions yes
representative fellows um yes I'm just
interested in exactly what you mean by
micro schools are those the like the
prenda ones where they do it online in
the morning and other things in the yeah
micro schools are a variety of different
offerings um you know it's it's kind of
a catch-all phrase to a lot of these
Alternatives um so you might see
Learning Centers you might see um you
know 10 person pods um there something
called Kai pods for example um you know
so we're seeing this explosion as I
don't think I think it's what 20 states
have some kind of education Freedom now
uh and we're seeing this explosion of
really the new term is edupreneur I
don't know if you've heard that term or
not but in the in the education fre
world edupreneur is becoming so I told
my kids I said if you're going to go
into business be an entrepreneur because
there's this huge market now for uh
alternative schooling uh in not just in
nation yes I just want to encourage you
my son was a drummer we homeschooled and
by the time was in fifth grade he was
drumming for the high school and he's
playing drums in California right now so
okay any further
questions okay thank you very much uh
Nancy Brennan Curtis
register
okay
um pardon
all right my comments complete thought
is two minutes and 5 Seconds I'll try to
be brief but uh good afternoon uh Mr
chair and honorable members of the
committee my name is Curtis register I'm
a resident of Durham a dad and I
consider myself to be a freedom loving
terrorist hating uh red blooded American
Patriot and I'm a proud product of
public school system now I'm a
transplant from a small North Carolina
town of 500 folks when I left it grew to
a boomman metropolis of 2000 folks I
attended Eno County Public Schools and
was lucky enough to attend a state
supported public College of the Virginia
Military Institute where I managed to
graduate with distinction I then went on
to serve 10 years active duty component
United States Marine Corps and I
honorably discharg as a major I would
not have achieved this without the
foundational support and principles of
our educational system New Hampshire
Public Schools consistently outperform
North Carolina Public Schools per uh
National Center for Education
statistics hb15 is a bad faith bill it
erodes resources and Trust in
established and accredited institutions
it will contribute to increased taxes
for all residents whether they use efas
or not it will expand the impact and
need of the teacher teacher shortage and
impact teacher salaries and retirement
it will expand the risk of fraudulent
schools and underage kids and lastly it
will undermine the quality of public
school education to all residents
regardless of Faith race Scholastic
aptitude or socioeconomic status now I'd
like the honorable members of the
committee to take a moment to imagine a
world where partisanship stopped at the
doors of educational institutions
imagine the quality of life Improvement
of scientific advancement economic
success and Civic engagement of a
well-educated societ Society in spend
instead of spending so much time money
and effort undermining established and
accomplished services for our
residents there are already enough
significant challenges in today's world
the American dream is under threat of
Extinction through rising cost of living
housing and taxes hb15 will not
contribute to solving any of these
crises let's invest our finite resources
for all New Hampshire residents not just
the desirous few please protect public
education funding vote down
hb15 and thank you very much for your
time and service thank you very much
Curtis sir thank you for your service
it is it yes go ahead not really a
question um as as a vet I know that you
took an oath to protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States and
I'm glad you're continuing to do that
ahead
Ved yes sir it is
correct made a b differ I guess you'd
have to ask the public but I hope
so thanks represent Burton have you made
a
difference don't have to answer that we
were both in Vietnam okay um going on
down and thank you for coming uh is
representative po poo
here
P oh good
okay then it be Jody
Underwood following thank you Mr chair
I'm y po representing May Mark hook
Buton and I'm here in support of this
bill uh some argue against this bill uh
saying that money will go to rich people
uh but it is exactly why we need to
support this uh Bill uh so rich parents
would contribute more what I see in my
district uh uh when uh parents picking
up kids from public schools uh sometimes
uh uh I I see some come and luxury Cs
and luxury German cars over all
expensive uh trucks if uh rich people
would contribute more we would create
more competition and Excellence um it
used to be illegal for rich people to
get free public school benefit no longer
so we cannot force them out but this
bill will create Financial incentive for
them to contribute more and stop using
uh free public school benefit that is
free but is very expensive for taxpayers
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions yes representative yeah
I'm not sure I understood that part you
were saying you want rich people to use
the education Freedom accounts and not
go to public
schools uh yeah yeah yes uh in my
district uh um uh in my town we have
like growing School population so uh
taxpayers will have to uh pay more taxes
to expand facilities like some um fixed
income people are getting uh priced out
of their homes through bigger taxes and
when Public School spends no of
$23,000 per people if some of those rich
people will get U uh uh $4,000 from
State and uh stop getting this free
public school benefit uh previously you
heard that it it's on average
$21,000 uh for private school tuition so
they obviously would need to contribute
more but I think it's win-win
situation thank you further questions
Underwood she's gone too
Amanda uh Weeden we d looks like an
N I don't
know are you insulting my handwriting
pardon
me everything else looks really good I
salmon welcome this late hour thank you
I was beginning to think my card was
lost um so my name is Amanda Weeden I'm
a little too close um I'm a home
education Advocate and I'm a republican
voter um so I'm an anomaly here because
um I believe hb15 is a fiscally
irresponsible
Bill the available finances and data and
lack of data for the current EFA program
point to additional tax obligations and
accountability issues if this bill
passes we've heard multiple moral
hearing the there's not been one
accurate fiscal argument in support of
this bill according to program data over
70% of participants were already paying
for their own
choices my children all four of them
qualify for the EFA program I am a
lowincome family we qualify for the full
amount and as a home educator in New
Hampshire I refuse I reject education
Freedom accounts because its taxpayer
funded
money the majority of students were not
switchers these are not kids coming out
of public schools as was pitched at the
beginning of this program they are not
switchers so they were not enrolled
they're not included in enrollment
numbers I've heard multiple times
Republicans say that this is a savings
to taxpayers but that's fuzzy
math these kids didn't cost 20 grand of
taxpayer money this EFA money of five
grand is an additional tax obligation
those kids were never included in the
funding guys this bill would allow
wealthy families who already pay private
school tuition tax pay your money for
their choice and this is
outrageous the young lady earlier who
referred to people like me as elitist
because we refuse this we reject this
I'm a Conservative Republican voter
consistently and this is an
outrageous outrageous
bill I pay for my own choice to home
educate my children and I should not
expect nor should anyone expect that my
elderly neighbor or the empty nesters
should pay for pottery wheels and dance
lessons for other people in this state
so I didn't get to all my things but I
just want to say there's too many
unanswered questions right now about
this current EFA program it would be
irresponsible to expand it and moral
arguments don't pay the
bills thank you any questions from the
committee yes profor McGuire thank you
so the reason you homeschool I guess is
what I heard um is because you think the
the results will be better than if you
your children went to public school
I would like to Define terms sir I'm a
home educator not a homeschooler there
are four distinct educational Pathways
in New Hampshire I am third pathway we
have very specific rights under the law
and I maintain that I follow the law and
rights and I do what is best for my
children without taxpayer funded
money yeah may I follow up yes you may
thank you so can you can you distinguish
between homeschool and home educate or
would representative I would love
to homeschooling has become a generic
term okay so everybody's homeschooling
and that could mean that could include
an EFA which is a fourth educational
pathway family that uses this taxpayer
money for home education related
expenses so it looks like home education
right same day-to-day experience except
they're using taxpayer money to pay for
their things I am not I'm scrimping and
saving as a low-income person with four
children a special needs child that I
pay for everything myself as a
Conservative Republican it is my
position that people need to pay for
their own
stuff so homeschooling is a generic term
but that is not the same as the third
educational pathway in New Hampshire
that is homeeducation designated under
RSA
193a so homeschooling generic fa could
be included in that right but home
education is very very specific under
the law so our rights equal access law
our requirements everything is very
plainly written in
law that's what I like I want to be left
alone I want to be left out of it I'm
very Freedom minded I'm a liberty person
and I'm grieved that I'm a Conservative
Republican here opposing this bill
publicly thank you very much all right
well
for clarification there are four
Pathways to compulsory education private
program all righty so with that Mr
chairman oh yes I don't think I actually
got the answer an answer to my first
question but yeah if I could try it
again or not no I I'm going to go to
representative Damon she had her hand up
for a question I guess thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
being here is there a organized group
of I'm trying to get the term right Home
Educators you better get it right and so
could you share with us about that
please is there an organized group of
Home Educators that I'm sorry I didn't
catch either you represent or that are
of like um Bel let me hop in here
because we this is not relative to the
to the
hb15 yes there that's a very very active
group that works amongst themselves
without all the regulations etc etc and
um and they we have groups that work
with them so but that we're just getting
way off the path here with respect Mr
chair I just wanted the name of the
group so we could follow up if we wanted
to my name is Amanda Weeden and I'm very
publicly available thank you thank
you the individuals the group
okay
VI I didn't see any tea on there but
okay but that's fine is Laura here yes
much my name is Laura Vincent and I live
in lden New
Hampshire it is very important that
hb15 be soundly defeated the best
opportunities for the children of New
Hampshire to have their educational
needs met and their educational
opportunities expanded is with New
Hampshire Public Schools the funds each
student receives through their EA around
$5,000 is not enough to pend private or
parochial school truition
this makes the EFA program useless for
families of limited incomes as Studies
have shown efas are utilized mostly by
families whose children already attend
nine Public
Schools when discussing special
education it is important that everyone
realizes the breadth of the spectrum of
needs being
discussed we may be talking about
children who need occasional one one of
small group tutoring to master difficult
Concepts or perhaps students with mared
hearing losss who may need preference or
seaing and the opportunity to frequently
have teacher instructions repeated I'm
sure that many private and parochial
schools can accommodate CH students with
these minimal types of special needs
however special education Also Serve
children with complex special needs
affecting their total educational
experiences so some students may need
one in one a
serving them all day to assist with
their physical needs or they may need to
utilize modified instructional materials
some students may need speech therapy
occupational therapy and or physical
therapy frequently to address the
developmental needs some students such
as those with severe visual or and or
hearing deficits need and deserve
instruction from teachers who are truly
proficient in skills such as reading bar
and communicating with American sign
language such students often need to
attend special schools access to their
home school
district private and perio student
schools cannot guarantee the provision
of such services for these students
students are sensely lose their right to
special education when they withdraw
from the public school system thank you
thank you very much any questions from
the committee thank you
not
here uh Kathleen SLO
sloven
kathle hello thank you my name is
Kathleen Slover and I'm from Portsmith a
quick story about my son's experience in
public school my son struggled through
Elementary School with ADHD and
non-verbal learning disability one of
his IEP reports wrote social concerns
are the biggest concern self-regulation
is a goal for him it is a concern that
these things may impact his ability to
be
successful after researching private
schools and homeschooling options I
realized these Alternatives were ill
equipped to deal with kids with learning
difference differences in fact many of
the private schools had a box that you
checked and they wouldn't accept you if
you got diagnosed with ADHD so we
decided to keep him in the public
schools fast forward to his sophomore
year at Portsmouth High School this is
what his report said he is a personable
eager hardworking student with a great
sense of humor and a solid moral compass
he's a curious student who wants to do
well in all his classes he is helpful
and considerate of the feelings and
needs of others when focused and engaged
he is a leader who sets great examples
and always contributes positively to
class the public school helped him
manage his learn learning disabilities
he will graduate college next year and
is a proud member of the New Hampshire
National Guard the Portsmouth public
school Community is a huge part of those
achievements and looking back it was the
best decision on behalf of the 90% of
the kids in New Hampshire that go to
public schools I would love for them to
have that successful story so please do
not siphon funds away from public
schools and vote no on
hb15 thank you thank you very much yes
represent Burton
um for the benefit of those who might
not know uh could you say what an IEP is
that you get from the public school
system that you may not get from a
private school correct um and I'm sorry
I don't even know what it stands for
individual um thank you um yeah he went
through a process that is legal it's
it's I got well versed in the legality
of it but first he had a 504 which is
just offering um a an outline of what
benefits he would things he would
benefit in the classroom and when those
didn't 100% work um we got
uh he got
re-evaluated um and then the public
school had to offer him Services all the
way through um sophomore year and it was
at the end of his sophomore year that we
decided he did not need those Services
anymore Mr chair a followup question Mr
chairman yes go ahead pay attention
now I'm trying to read the next pan I
have a I have I have a question to ask
ask her yeah well
thank you were you involved in
developing those IEPs yes we I met
monthly at the schools with the teachers
and I'm going to tell you it wasn't
always
easy um but by the end of every school
year we were making progress I think one
of the things that came out of all of
this was his um confidence and
personage was left intact he um the
public schools did not make him an a
student because he's not an a student
but what they did do is make him a
resilient he has amazing amount of
stuven um his ability to manage his ADHD
because in the National Guard you have
to admit that you have not you can't be
treated for ADHD he does not take
medication for it and the public school
worked with him and I was there the
entire time a lot of his teachers uh who
came into the IEP meeting all the way
through said hey you know what I have
ADHD um so the Public Schools strike me
as the um you know what's the what's the
quote on the uh Statute of Liberty they
take everybody and what they produce is
solid members of the community um this
is a kid that went through boot camp
that goes to college he's doing it all
and he's doing it here in New Hampshire
so I think the I think the public
schools thank you thank you thank you
very much good question uh
David must be
me is that f i s t r fater flater that's
David we're up here trying to discuss
that whether was an A and I or listen I
all right check check
sience you might fill this up a little
bit thank you uh good afternoon everyone
and my how far afternoon we really are
uh thank you to the chair and committee
for having me uh my name is David flater
I'm from sop and suan County and I'm
here today in opposition of House Bill
115 for the entirety of my pre-ol
education I attended one of our Town's
excellent Public Schools over my time at
sopi I was able to both learn and
Achieve with which Advanced me into the
person I am before you my peers and I
have been able to attend college enter
the workforce or pursue other goals with
the knowledge that we are backed by a
wealth of quality teachings I'll admit
sonop wasn't always perfect but a lot of
the issues people raise as reasons to
send their children to private schools
on vouchers won't be solved by just
sending these kids to a school that
doesn't report to the state when I
wanted to change something in my school
I applied to be a student body
representative
when I held a seat on the student
council we held sway over school events
and I was included on panels of students
that met to advise our principle on
rules and policy the thing to keep in
mind is that public schools can and do
educate their attendees to a high
standard and are good places for
developing children to Bay the reason I
feel confident being here before you as
a college freshman is because of the
passion and skills imbued in me by my
public school
education thank you for your time thank
you very very much where are you going
to school David I'm going to the
University of Tampa in Florida that's
wonderful wonderful we got a good hockey
team down Tampa
yeah all right any questions for
David congratulations and thank you
thank you sir uh Paul
Connell good late afternoon chairman lad
and members of the committee it's nice
to be before you again after a a little
a little break um I'm Jamal Connell I'm
the vice chair of the Manchester Board
of school committee and uh I'm here on
behalf of the committee um in most what
I'll distinguish the piece that will
come from me but uh the the manest board
school committee does not support this
bill and uh we've discussed it our
education legislation chairman had to
leave Dr par I think would have been
following me up but he has uh
distributed paperwork just now that I'd
ask you to look at and he's also
extensively gone into articles and and
and studies that you could look at
that's um but I'm not going to you know
not I'm not a fan of of voucher systems
to begin with and the EFA in particular
but I think we might those of you who
know me kind of know that so I I'm here
today because I think this should ought
to be an easy decision with great
respect to my friends who who uh you
know uh would would would put first and
for foremost uh the fiscal rectitude and
responsibility I I I Echo what I heard
here earlier about the problems with the
current bill already you know the the
the the audit thing right 50 a random 50
uh people receiving these accounts was
was looked at and 25% of them had errors
in them so we know that the other the
only other place that's published we
look at the list of places that have
gotten the money 25% of the money is
going to
amazon.com this money has been spent for
instance down at we don't know where a
lot of it is but we know that it's been
used to go to a trip down to Mystic
conne to go to the aquarium I guess they
could afford the gas to go right past
the one in Boston because it was the
wasn't good enough I I just don't
understand when we're facing the kind of
problems that we're facing in this state
financially of this Bia where we're
finding the time in energy to remember
this bill would only do this the only
people it's going to affect are people
who are earning greater than the medium
income median income in the state of New
Hampshire this money would go only to
people now we we we heard a lady talk
about snap we look at free and reduce
lunch
150% of of the of the the federal
poverty rate we have schools in
Manchester with 85 90% free and reduced
lunch but that's limited to people at
150% when it comes to special education
Mr chairman we've got three and a half
thousand kids in the city of Manchester
who are specially educated for instance
we have 65 nurses in the city of
Manchester one in each of our 20 schools
and then the rest of them some of them
are oneon-one with indiv with students
we have students with great needs we're
spending think about this in
transportation costs alone for special
education we're spending $113 million a
year now when I it it hurts me and I I I
I do empathize that parenting is I've
got four kids parenting is hard and when
you have kids with extra challenges it's
extra hard and I know and I hear the
pain I hear it all the time from parents
but to say that public schools are not
making efforts in this regard we're
spending $17 million a year in Services
Beyond that's not for all the employees
we have that's for outside Services
we're sending children all over to 28
different towns and cities to get them
the services they need we have
individual students who've gotten close
to a million dollars worth of worth of
special education so it's an insult that
thousands and thousands of people who
work on these children every day to help
them and to bring them forward so I
would I would say one last thing if I
could Mr chairman I I think that if the
problem with public education is really
there and as extensive as some of our
citizens have said here today I think
the the State Board of Education perhaps
the other one now should be the other
committee should be looking at that you
know if if our you know if our schools
are not doing what what we claim that
they're doing so I would ask you to
oppose it because it's a luxury at very
best we can't afford and we need
accountability
going thank you you say Sean's not going
to be here too no Shawn had to leave he
he to leave he did he did but I'd be
happy to accept any questions if anybody
has are there any
questions thank you all right thank you
very much and much appreciate your work
thank
you
good evening good evening thank you Mr
uh chair and the members of the
committee um my name is simita thur and
I'm from exitor New Hampshire um when I
first saw uh this bill that it's uh the
universal education Freedom accounts I
said wow excellent finally something
that can you know that everybody can
really on but as soon as I looked at the
wording I realized that it's not
Universal at all and that it just
benefits now if Bill 115 passes it will
benefit now only the wealthiest or in
addition to everybody else the
wealthiest people from New Hampshire and
it will not uh improve the benefits for
the lowest income members of our
community uh the voucher amounts simply
do not not cover enough uh to for
tuition and expenses in most uh private
schools and even
if a family finds a private school that
could fit uh the amount that the budget
covers and it's across the state they
have no way to get their child to that
school because vouchers do not cover
Transportation um
expenses um and with uh Governor Kelly
aot um
mentioning or U warning us that there
would be budget cuts um I'm wondering
how the increase in the cost to the
state will be covered uh because now
with
basically uh education Freedom accounts
being open to everyone um the cost is
going to Skyrocket to over100 million
and I see two ways of how those costs
would be covered um both which are kind
of scary one is the increase in property
taxes uh and the ironic thing about that
is that he would be all of the members
of our community including the lowest
income ones who would be through their
property taxes paying for the vouchers
that the most wealthy families will be
getting
um and the other is by uh reducing the
programs in schools and my children work
hugely benefited from music from art
from World languages they were taught in
their uh Cooperative Middle School in
stratum New Hampshire thank you so I'm
voting voting giving my opinion uh to
oppose Bill uh 115 thank you very much
C I don't know I I couldn't make up
a it looks like
Haley yes yeah it's Kaye Ned is
here
done hello everyone I'm Su Hannan I'm
from dairy and I come speaking for
myself in opposition of hb15 I'm an
educator and I work in the public
schools in
Manchester as you're well aware those of
us working hard in public education do
not take kindly to these voucher schemes
that have infiltrated this and other
states as they siphon money away from
the public school systems and have
little to no
accountability in this state we are
transparent about public school systems
and the funding and uh holding public
meetings that account for every cent
that we spend showing how much every
person in the district makes and being
fiscally responsible with taxpayer money
why then are we even thinking about
allowing cart blanch for private
education and not asking for any
accountability for where this money goes
how does it happen in New Hampshire that
a private entity gets to spend taxpayer
dollars freely without audit reports and
without making sure that applications
are done correctly if the New Hampshire
retirement system said we're not sharing
our reports with you and our audits are
yours but we're still not going to share
them would you let that stand the data
belongs to the state but we don't have
it I pay my taxes and I'm very proud to
support the dairy Public School District
because I want an educated
citizenry less money from the state for
Education will will end up requiring
local property taxes to go up reading
comments on social media about taxes I
don't see that as fairing well for those
we have
elected for districts like Manchester
where I work that have a tax cap it will
cut Services
deeply maybe you don't realize that
ultimately it's the taxpayers who pay
for these students at least twice in
most cases more often than you realize
students are enrolled in Charter or
private schools and the money that
should have come to the district is
taken away from the public schools to go
toward
vouchers the thing is those kids end up
coming back and we have to pay for them
again because that money does not come
back to us that's a huge
problem again I come in opposition of
hb15 and I'm glad to take any questions
thank you very much any
questions thank you for teaching thank
B you don't want to talk about that too
much right now I did the best I could
I'm I'm Brian beton Court sorry I'm
Brian beton Court um resident in h um
and taxpayer of uh hopon New Hampshire
I'm here today to testify in support of
House Bill 115 removing the income tests
for the EFA program as a father of three
incredible children our family struggled
to find a fit within our Town's public
school system with the co Public School
shutdowns my wife and I created a micro
school for our young kids and then we
were introduced to some great
alternative education options in New
Hampshire my wife and I are engineers
and small business owners and we
struggle to afford the out-of- pocket
cost of our children's education while
still being forced to pay for the public
school system which isn't a good fit for
our family it's a family of five in new
new in New Hampshire the income limit
for EFA eligibility in 2025 is going to
be
$131,000 with two hardworking parents
our family income exceeds the current
limit but with the high cost of living
in New Hampshire housing real estate
taxes utilities food medical care we're
struggling while paying for education
investment the income test encourages
parents with desperately needed skills
to leave the workforce it has led my
employees to refuse overtime or even
full-time scheduling to be eligible for
benefits this income test does not
exclude the rich from receiving aid but
instead is disincentivizing hard work
and exacerbating the New Hampshire
skilled labor for short Force shortage
this isn't about investment bankers and
day Traders this is about plumbers
electrician policemen engineers and
contractors who make New Hampshire the
great and are tight Supply House Bill
115 e efas is will not eliminate our
fam's education costs but will remove
the hard work penalty and keep the best
New Hampshire workers in the labor force
heard a lot about how there is going to
be a a net positive cost for HB 115 um I
live in hopkington we spent an average
of $28,000 per student per 180 days of
education
$28,000 the education the EFA Grant be
about
$4,400 that's a 85 5% reduction in cost
children thank you very very much are
there
questions thank
you thank
good evening good evening I'll try to be
quick and thank you chairman Laden
honorable members of the committee I'm
Claudia Stell I'm resident of aworth I'm
a retired educ educator with over 30
years teaching experience in public
schools in New Hampshire I'm active in
the economic Justice Mission um group of
the United Church of Christ and I have
taught and been educated in both public
and private schools I have a lot of
respect for a variety of educational
opportunities Public Schools offer uh
they're the Bedrock of our economy and
our democracy and they allow for an
educated citizenry and they give
students an opportunity from whatever
background they have to be have a leg up
and to um to have a stepping stone to
equality so I think I strongly support
public schools I I think that um they
also our community schools are the pride
and joy of our of our towns um I live in
Sullivan County which is the second
poorest county in New Hampshire and yet
our Regional School District supports
Community Schools Regional
um Junior highs or middle schools uh a
regional uh high school and we have a
variety of programs um for special needs
children for and AP classes and Career
Education and arts and sports I think we
do a really good job um I know that I
our children went to that school it
wasn't perfect I've taught in that
school and I know that I didn't do a
perfect job every day but we worked our
hardest and we believed in our children
and we loved them what we the staff
cannot make up the difference for is
budget cuts and budget cuts were talked
about earlier today I would like to say
that there are two kinds of budget cuts
I think that people see one would be
when the budget doesn't pass it becomes
news that the budget was voted down I
think the budget cuts that people that
most of us do not see are the budget
cuts that come from the administration
the school board the budget committees
that say um sharpen your pencils again
we can't afford to we can't afford to go
to the voters with with with a budget
that's this
high so and I the other I just think
that that this um will also create more
income inequality the children who can't
afford who come from families that can
afford to pay for uh public for private
education will now be get a subsidy and
the children who come from families that
are financially strapped
the the money from the fa isn't going to
make a difference for them thank you
very much other
questions thank you for the 30 years
welcome thank you and I did send this to
everyone so thank you oh there you we do
have one question yeah just it's very
good to see a fellow from Fall Mountain
District yes thank
you see at end of the yeah we're
there well thank you very much for all
of your patience you are such good
listeners all the teachers in this room
would be so proud of all of
you so thank you so much for that
because I know that that's really hard
so thank you my name is Lisa Goodwin and
I a principal at Cornerstone Christian
Academy in Opie New Hampshire but I'm
also a 30-year retired public school
teacher I love the public
school I love what it did for my
child but all I'm asking for you to do
is to consider the whatever it takes
mindset for children because as you
you've heard over over and over again
today we've heard words like the public
school helps most kids or the majority
I'm here to speak about those kiddos
that we have in our school that the
public school has either failed them or
they just um it wasn't the right fit for
who they are as people I hope I don't
know if any of you have children but
each child is unique and each child is
special and each one requires different
things for their education we have
several students uh that have come from
the public school because it wasn't the
right fit and all I'm asking is that you
would consider whatever it takes mindset
and we have many many families who can't
um access the funding because they're
just above that line we have 61% of our
um families who do access the EF and
thank you so much for supporting that
but we also have families who it's
really really hard for them because in
that application that they fill out
there's nothing that talks about what
their struggles are in life whether they
have four children or as you heard
somebody else somebody had cancer in
their family and they had an unexpected
CA somebody lost a job all of that is
not a story that is told online and all
you can see is that number and so all
I'm asking is for the whatever it takes
mindset when you look at those kiddos
who the public school is not the right
fit for um and I thank you for um
listening to all of us today and I I'm
hoping that you'll make um the decision
what's best for all kids thank you thank
you very
much yes representative yes thank thank
you Mr chairman thank thank you for uh
taking my question roughly what's
tuition at your in college currently are
currently our tuition is
10,500 and it does not um it's not the
accurate number for what it takes to
educate the child but we know that we
can't ask for more than that right now
because it's really hard for those
families and also is a very rural um not
wealthy area of our state as you know so
uh we have a gap and we have to make up
for that quite a bit with um
fundraising thank you further questions
thank you very much oh yes go ahead rep
I I don't even know the answer to that
so I'm asking off the cuff can you tell
me what you provide for special ed kids
well unfortunately we cannot we don't
have a St we don't have the money to
afford a special ed teacher now my heart
is for the struggling learner would I
love to have a special Edge education
teacher on our staff absolutely we do
have students with um IEPs and we
struggle with how to help them because
we don't have the staff to accommodate
their needs we do our very very best
because we have small group
instruction
however they can't go back to where they
were from due to some of the really hard
stories and I'm not going to go through
those stories with you but they come
from really hard stories about how the
public school was not the right fit for
their family and they can't go back and
so and they both work so what do they do
they find the closest other source of
education for their family
um so I wish we could provide that
because I love the struggling Learners
they are my jam but um we can't provide
for them because we don't have the money
for a staff member because we want to
keep the cost down for a large
population of people thank you
y yes represent
bton I'm surprised by your last
statement because the Federal Law
requires every student to get a free and
appropriate education in the least
restrictive environment but your school
can't provide that and I guess some of
the other schools can't either is that
correct we cannot provide what the
public school does because the public
school guarantees those things we as a
private school cannot guarantee those
things but we can do our very very best
in a small group instruction environment
to provide the best that we can but we
don't have if the IEP requires that
child to have a staff member to be with
them we can't and we let them know
before they sign on the agreement that
that is not something that we can
provide so they understand that going
into our school and please know I I
respect what you're doing I'm not in any
way critical at that thank you for your
answer y thank you very much any further
questions thank you thank you so much uh
good hello thank you for this
opportunity uh my name is Katherine abot
I'm from
Portsmith um I'm a traditional home
educator uh he EFA is not homeschool and
I feel needs to be kept separate and
clearly
defined um I receive zero funding from
any government agencies my family's
annual income is under the federal
poverty guidelines and I'm a single
mother so I no way feel that I am an
elitist as commented earlier um but this
in no way has kept me from providing a
robust quality multifaceted education uh
for my children I'm able to do this by
living within my means and being a good
Steward of the resources the Lord has
given me and by his grace um proponents
for Universal efas claim that the
program CRI will be giving families a
choice uh this hearkens to we're from
the government and we're here to help um
I maintain that Universal efas are not
giving parents a choice parents have
always had a choice parents have a
choice uh Universal efas will be giving
families a higher tax burden and more
government oversight um I see that there
is a lot of money to be made and
political power to be gained through a
EFA policy um it's my my position that
Universal efas will be Paving the way
for increased taxes new taxes such as a
sales tax increased oversight and
regulation imposed on non-public school
families overreaching policy by
government agencies and the loss of the
New Hampshire
Advantage um I've noted these concerns
out of looking at other states that have
implemented such programs I believe uh
South Dakota and Arizona um I believe
those were what I was looking at um I
feel the unversal EF EFA bill is
dangerous and uh the endgame is more
government control and intrusion and
families that just want to be kept out
of it um I'm respectfully requesting
that the state be fiscally responsible
with taxpayer money and a good Steward
of the resources by voting against
universally a face thank you no
questions thank you very
much uh Dave de that's
it you almost hit the lottery here
so uh I pronounce it Dew but you my
whole family pronounces it de well well
there's a the Pew in Buffalo New York I
families from New York from the Dutch
area where it's the Pew um and I also
had my daughter here until recently to
uh to have a kid who was in public
school I'm my name is Dave Dew I'm from
Candia New Hampshire I here I'm opposed
to lifting the cap uh my only claim to
fame is that I was on the board of
Selectmen uh in Candia for I served one
term and then I uh didn't run again
there are some very good private schools
in this state including holderness
Academy St Paul's School dairyfield
uh Philips exitor Academy they cost
$50,000
plus um they have program St Paul's
School has a program if you make the
family makes less than
$150,000 tuition free Philips exitor
Academy if the family makes
$125,000 or less tuition
free if they're making hundreds of
thousands or millions of dollars and
there are many more in this state than
you might think they pay the full vote
so my question to this committee is why
should lowincome New Hampshire
taxpayers contribute money to give
$5,200 to people in the EFA program
making hundreds of thousands or millions
of
dollars I mean we've got people in
Candia who are scraping by to pay their
taxes they're living on Social Security
and their savings they paid off their
mortgage over a lifetime and now they
find out they're getting a tax bill that
probably approaches what they were
paying for a mortgage instead I would
say we ought to be paying money to the
public schools
because governor sonunu in his executive
summary for
20242 had a graph showing that for 15
years from 2008 to
2023 state aid to education went up 12
.3% inflation went up
41% we've been underfunding our schools
not just that's Democratic Republican
legislators and administrations for
years and the result has been people are
dissatisfied with their public schools
that we've been under funding for 15
years or more we need to put more money
in our Public
Schools I went to Public Schools my kids
went to Public Schools they're the
backbone of the educational system of
this country and this state and we ought
to fund
them thank you very much any questions
from the
committee thank you again thank you uh
Reena
pit very dedicated Bunch especially
those asking questions after that
evening Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Rina Pettit I live
in Lichfield the petition I will be
reading to you was circulated over the
past three days and collected 35
signatures of which 25 are Lichfield
residents and the remainder are
residents of Goffstown Londoner
Manchester Mont Veron and summersworth
we oppose House Bill
115 the state legislature has an
opportunity to act to make meaningful
school funding change this legislative
session New Hampshire schools have
affirmed over and over decade after
decade the state's constitutional
obligation to fund an adequate education
and reaffirm this in the Superior Court
decisions in
2023 the state continues to fail to meet
its Constitution obligation to fund
public education leaving a significant
Gap in funding between what it
contributes per student and the actual
cost of Education the differen is
driving New Hampshire's property tax
rates to be among the very highest of
the 50 states in the conal case the
court wrote base adequacy can be no less
than $
7,356 1 per pupil per year and the true
cost is much likely much higher than
that if the legislature adopted such a
change it could shift more of the
responsibility for funding public
education to the state and reduce local
property taxes hb15 relative to
Universal eligibility for Education
Freedom account program could cost the
state approximately 102 to $130 million
in the 2025 2026 school year in closing
those schools are funds that would be
diverted from the education trust fund
the state's public school funding source
is imperative for the state legislature
to ensure all such funds are used to
benefit public schools and the property
taxpayers supporting them and not divert
that funding for Universal efas as New
Hampshire residents parents and property
taxpayers we are calling on the
legislature to develop an equitable and
comprehensive school funding solution
that works for every community in New
Hampshire it's time for the state to
meet its constitutional funding
obligation to public schools and provide
property tax relief significantly thank
you thank you very much any questions
from the committee thank you very much
house hard getting out of that se
sitting it all day long isn't it Deborah
okay good good evening chairman L and
members of the education funding
committee it's good to be here um my
name is Deborah H I am president of the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire I represent 3500 members
mostly in prek through 12 public
education as well as uh faculty at uh
both public and private universities and
um City and town employees across the
state and I'm going to try and not be
too repetitive with things that other
people have already said but uh the New
Hampshire Constitution guarantees every
granted State Child the right to the
opportunity of a great public education
no matter which district they live in
and that is a robust education not just
Bare Bones they have the right to small
class sizes robust curriculum uh
individual attention academic support
when they need it behavioral support and
uh you know a complete education that
prepares them for the workforce the
service and higher education and uh
civic participation in their communities
that's what we are building in our state
that's what our communities
deserve and the state has the obligation
to fund
that that is a have to with our revenue
and our
funding the um voucher program is a want
to so spending on vouchers that's
something that the legislation
legislature has decided to do and we are
opposing hb15 because making that
program Universal is taking limited
resources that we have in the
state with um decreasing revenues coming
in and a predicted shortfall this fiscal
year at the end of the year and the uh
governor already telling us we have to
tighten our belt and cut the state
budgets you aren't going to have enough
money to fund both we can't afford two
education systems was that two minutes
already that's two
minutes okay in that case I will pass
around my testimony but you have an
obligation to all of our public school
students to fully fund public schools
and as much as it is great that parents
want to find a better fit the state does
not have an obligation to fund it and
they can't afford it right now and you
can read the rest of it in my
testimony all right thank you uh next
yeah hi everyone good evening we don't
usually get to say that up here um my
name is Christine cyber representative
Christine cyber I uhhuh if you're a rep
you should really push name down oh yeah
I'm sorry I forgot you don't have to but
it's nice kind of get you up in the anti
a little bit I forget sometimes um yeah
so my name is representative Christine
cyber I'm from Manchester's board one
and I won't take up much of your time
but I really enjoyed some of the just
previous speakers that we had I feel
like we're hearing a lot of very
important voices that need to be heard
in this conversation there's like really
two main arguments that are very highly
politicized in this whole um just
everything we're talking about with the
expansion and the vouchers in
general um and a lot of bad arguments
going around with the entire thing the
one huge problem I have with this with
this especially this particular bill
with expanding the vouchers is the lack
of accountability and
transparency and you know the biggest
thing is the audit we weren't allowed to
well we're supposed to be able to look
at the audit it's very confusing as to
why we cannot subpoena the papers we
need to do I feel like we should not
take any action on this particular Bill
until we can fully get those numbers to
see what is going on with that and is
this worth expanding and also how much
money is just not being accounted for um
I feel like a big part of folks that are
being left out of this argument as well
are the taxpayers who have no children
such as myself it is not fair for them
especially with with a large majority of
our of our population being over you
know being in the elderly age range and
retired they can't afford that they live
on fixed incomes and this will cause
property taxes to go up so in turn I
would just like us to actually keep the
school choice we've had all along and
fully fund our public education system
which honestly we never tried to do in
the first place when the lawsuits were
brought up back with Claremont thank
thank you for your time and I appreciate
um yeah everything you guys are doing
[Music]
Hawkins well if you have to go you got
to go that's right we've had several
that good evening Brian um thank you uh
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record Brian Hawkins representing
Nea New Hampshire looking forward to
getting to know the new committee
members here um as we go forward um so
I'm here today in opposition to House
Bill 115 uh as you are aware there's two
Court decisions that have been uh making
their way through the process but it
thus far has reaffirmed that the state
is not meeting its obligation under our
Constitution to provide an adequate
public education I'm going to skip a lot
of things that I have in some written
testimony um but since 1 15 House Bill
115 would throw open the door to
diverting more public funds for a second
private voucher education I think you
need to look at the experience that the
states who have done so have had with
this um adventure and that is uh you
know first we'll look at Arizona the
program is costing a billion dollars a
year now in taxpayer dollars it is
responsible for half of the budget
deficit that they faced uh um this past
year and in order to fill that budget
Gap they had to do significant cuts to a
number of programs including to higher
education um and we know that the only
other place for that to be made up at
the local level as has been stated today
is local property uh taxes because as we
have seen in New Hampshire and in the
states that have expanded to either a
universal program or even
significantly uh with some of the
proposals that were passed uh excuse me
failed last year uh here in the state 75
to 80% of those students are students
who were not in a public school and so
that is new funds that the state has to
uh come up with and as I said is now um
a second of education system um that uh
the state is obligating itself to fund
so I'll close with saying instead of
sending more taxpayer money to private
schools we should should focus on the
public schools where nearly 90% of our
children attend not take money away from
them we need to do things like reduce
class sizes we need to solve the teacher
shortage and the educator shortage
crisis that we are under um we need to
fund special
education um and we need to reduce class
sizes and so with these questions in
mind um and Hampshire respectively asks
the education funding committee to find
House Bill 115 in expedient to legislate
I appreciate your time happy to take any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions for yes represent McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Hawkins does your organization represent
just teachers or is it other employees
of schools sure uh we represent a
variety of uh employees uh in schools
but um they are teachers PA
professionals various support staff
roles in schools some of it depends on
the uh School District uh but not not um
principles further
questions thank you very much good
evening thank you now I got some cards
here we went through and I'm going to
read some names off in case somebody's
here that's you know one Aid it's ad
here nope uh
Haley
Megan
Jody she left I know
Nancy
Linda he's not here
Laura
Richard
Charles Janine she Al Leah Lee
you
well
so what oh absolutely absolutely you
know if
lottery exactly
yes thank you very
much can left your died out get
ack okay so just want to say can you get
Au yes uh okay I lived in New Hampshire
all my life I uh was attached to the
fifth special forces in VI on from
August 69 to August
70 okay so I was born in nashwa I went
to Catholic schools All My Life as a
matter of fact in the eth grade my my
classmate was Mark aot the
governor's father and I also went to
Bishop Bradley with him graduated from
there so I I have that association with
them um I am against this bill even
though I went to Catholic schools all my
life and it's interesting because when I
was going to Catholic school you know
how they funded it the nuns the nuns
were paid a dollar a day and the rest
was paid from bingo bingo is a big thing
and that's that's footed our school so
uh I'm opposed to this because even
though I went to Catholic schools my
parents paid for it tax paid didn't have
to pay for it and it was our choice and
I thought it was appropriate because I
had the special education I want I had
half a day in French and half a day I
had Catholic Education so the whole time
nobody else had to pay for it we paid
for it because that's what we wanted we
wanted it differently so Meanwhile my
kids went to public school in Manchester
and one of the teachers Mrs barui helped
my my uh oldest granddaughter that went
to that school fifth grade when she
transferred from m m New York she had
troubles that Miss buuy helped her a lot
and there's other instances my another
of his sister she ended up being the
national championship goalie and so as a
result she got a full boat scholarship
to Cushing Academy it was 75,000 a year
after one year she says no I'm going
back to Central so I I really think the
public schools do a good job and I'm
going to I'm going to insult you guys
but to me the main problem is we're all
fighting over the money because you guys
didn't do your job you're not fulfilling
the Constitution and adequately funding
our education system and I think that's
wrong on your part I know a lot of the
voters say I don't want to pay the taxes
I'm willing to pay the taxes because we
need it because it's for our kids and to
not do that is
it's negligent it's against the
Constitution so to me we just you guys
just celebrated cutting the interest and
dividence tax would cost cut $160
million off our budget we could have
used that for the schools so to me I'm
willing to have a sales tax income tax
both taxes whatever I don't care let's
take care of our our kids for all of the
kids that way we take care of all the
needs because I think like has been said
a lot of people are dedicated to the
kids and and in another incident one of
my children and uh I was very homophobic
came out to a guidance counselor and
helped her get through school until she
was felt comfortable enough to tell me
about it so the school systems the the
people School teachers are so dedicated
they really love the kids they care for
the kids they best interest and we got
to give them the resources they can
continue to do a good job that's my say
so please raise taxes get money for the
kids please thank you Roger yeah any any
questions from the committee okay okay
no I don't see thank you for waiting
through all right thank you is there
anybody else in the crowd that wishes to
speak thank you then I will declare this
hearing
adjourn